une heure tu as une heure c'est c'est
pas une interview tu as tout ton temps
on va parler physique on a trois
questions
sur plutôt sur les changements
climatiques l'impact la ressource
l'énergie la montagne et la montagne ça
échelle je le sais
et ensuite cette question sur l'économie
donc nous passons en version question
pour un champion
et donc qui veut gagner des Millions
parce que ça aussi c'est un truc que toi
tu es con mais moi je disais question
pour un champion il y en a 10 j'ai
jamais réussi à faire en sorte que dans
les émissions de jeu il y a des
questions qui portent sur
l'environnement
j'avais j'avais j'avais essayé j'avais
essayé d'en parler à Fabrice bonifet
justement parce que Fabrice Bonifay
directeur du développement durable du
Groupe Bouygues un tout petit média qui
s'appelle TF1
qui faisait un tout petit jeu à grande
audience à un moment qui veut gagner des
millions et on n'a jamais gagné des
millions en attendant des questions sur
l'environnement je trouve ça un peu
dommage mais bon t'inquiète on fera un
poste à 450 000 vues et on va lancer
cette idée alors
Jean-Marc je vais faire une biographie
mais hyper court si vous voulez la
longue et la non autorisée elle est dans
L'Express et
et on avait dit qu'on en parlait pas
alors Jean-Marc tu es ingénieur passé
par Polytechnique Télécom Paris
tu as pour l'ADEME conçu le bilan
carbone et depuis tous ces sujets de
carbone ton véhicule TV véhicule pour
des carboner l'économie c'est à la fois
le chiffre project donc tu es président
et à la fois carbone 4 dont tu es
co-fondateur
et tu préfères qu'on parle de tes sujets
plutôt que de ta personne et c'est ce
qu'on va faire mais je vais quand même
dire que tu es très engagé auprès des
étudiants donc j'ai déjà parlé des jeux
c'est pas combien d'heures de cours à
mine mais c'est quand même accessible
gratuitement tout le temps sur Youtube
donc franchement pourquoi s'en priver tu
es engagé pour tous les publics
d'ailleurs la preuve excellent
vulgarisateur je sais ils sont là mais
ils sont là aussi magnifique un kilo 5
et l'autre plus léger mais néanmoins
très très important également que tu as
coordonné le
j'ai pas fait grand-chose j'ai fait
après ça
il a fait la préface donc je te poserai
pas des questions dedans mais en
inspirant
moi aussi je l'ai lu deux fois parce que
j'avais pas tout compris mais n'empêche
sérieux il y a des pages sur l'industrie
qui qui sont vraiment enfin qui valent
qui veulent le déplacement donc je vous
engage à je fais un peu de pub est-ce
que vous avez fait pour sauver la
planète aujourd'hui
nous on a invité Jean-Marc jean-clovici
alors donc
planter le décor côté climat on est en
train de mais c'est pas la bonne échelle
pas les bons ordres de grandeur les
règles de jeu de l'industrie direct du
jeu de l'industrie sont en train
d'évoluer alors comme j'ai préparé cette
course ça se voit pas mais quand même
j'ai regardé tout ce qui se passait au
niveau européen il se passe plein de
trucs pour une industrie 0 carbone j'ai
lu ça je me suis mis il l'appelle déjà 0
carbone le truc il n'existe pas toi ça
m'a gratté aux entournures zéro émission
ils disent et ça parle déjà d'arbitrage
alors je sais pas si tu as lu un article
dans le monde j'ai eu beaucoup le monde
le matin au petit déj je vais vous lire
la phrase parce que moi elle m'a fait
réagir on est en train de subventionner
l'industrie demain et de faire gagner
en compétitivité l'Europe donc c'est ça
l'objectif
et il est question de la compatibilité
de ces mesures avec le Green Deal déjà
donc moi je lis et deux points ouvrez
les guillemets ces projets industriels
stratégiques bénéficieront de conditions
avantageuses pour jusque là on est tous
contents il pourrait même être déclaré
d'intérêt public waouh ce qui virgule
explique la commission signifie la
Commission européenne
qu'ils ne pourront pas être empêchés
pour des raisons environnementales alors
là c'est chaud c'est non j'ai pas rêvé
il y a une contradiction monumentale tu
rigoles j'ai rêvé ou j'ai pas rêvé j'ai
pas rêvé je ne sais pas j'ai pas lu cet
article du Monde je te l'envoie et voilà
je te l'envoie après j'ai suffisamment
fréquenté les journalistes pour savoir
que c'est pas dans l'article qui faut
regarder c'est dans les textes eux-mêmes
de la Commission européenne voilà il
faut compter à la source pour voir ce
qu'il y a dedans il y a rien encore
c'est donc de toute façon
on dit mais
la commission pour voir exactement
quelle herbatim exact parce que je sais
que tout résumé déjà une déformation
donc c'est un peu
mais d'abord j'ai un rapide quiz à la
salle parce que je voudrais voir si vous
êtes réveillés qui a lu le ptes
qui a lu le monde sans fin
c'est bien pour ça qu'on en a mis bien
sûr quand même mondial il y a aussi des
images dans le p.e.f oui
il y en a aussi dans l'entreprise
contributive et c'est moi qui les ai
faites et c'est pour ça que c'est pas
aussi bien que celle de blanche il n'y a
pas à tortiller question vraiment
importante combien l'industrie
pèse-t-elle dans notre PIB
pas pas de la région de la vallée de
l'art dans ça on vous l'a dit tout à
l'heure si vous avez retenu
[Musique]
mais c'est bien c'est bien je suis
contente vraiment ils sont bien alors à
toi donc trois questions physiques
première question très macro impact
climat globaux avec ton amour pour la
montagne tu peux contextualiser ici tu
peux nous parler des Alpes de l'eau des
températures
que se passe-t-il que se passe-t-il que
va-t-il se passer
vous l'avez déjà constaté vous avez pas
besoin de moi pour ça vous avez constaté
que le climat est en train déjà de
changer que il y a globalement une
couverture du manteau neigeux qui est en
train de diminuer et du reste ça a été
particulièrement marqué cet hiver
vous pouvez constater que le printemps
arrive plus tôt vous pouvez constater
que les étés sont plus chauds et là
aussi vous avez pas besoin de moi pour
tout ça voilà des choses que vous ne
constatez pas quand vous êtes dans la
montagne mais qui arrive également en ce
moment c'est que le niveau de l'océan
est en train de monter alors il monte
parce que l'eau se dilate quand on la
chauffe exactement comme le métal et le
niveau de l'océan monte également parce
que vous avez une pote c'est un petit
morceau de la Mer de Glace et un petit
morceau du glacier des Bossons qui une
fois qu'il a fondu se retrouve dans
l'océan et puis c'est valable pour tous
les glaciers du monde et c'est également
maintenant valable pour le Groenland qui
a commencé à fondre depuis une vingtaine
d'années avec des mécanismes et ce qu'on
appelle les rétroactions c'est-à-dire le
phénomène qui agit sur lui-même qui font
que ces rétroaction que maintenant à
partir de maintenant quoi qu'on fasse le
wildland ne s'arrêtera plus de fondre
donc la question est simplement de
combien il va fondre et à quelle vitesse
mais le coût est parti et on va se
retrouver d'ici quelques siècles avec
trois à 6 mètres d'eau en plus dans
l'océan mondial à cause de la fonte du
Groenland
ce que vous pouvez constater également
c'est que le pilier des drues est
descendu et ça c'est la fonte du
pergélissol vous savez que vous avez en
montagne un isotherme 0 un ça je pense
que ça vous parle cette isotherme 0 est
plus bas l'hiver plus haut l'été mais
jusqu'à une époque récente au-delà de il
remontera rarement au-delà de 4000
mètres ce qui veut dire que
l'essentiel de la montagne se situant au
dessus de 3000 ou 3500 mètres en fait le
sol était gelé en permanence et le
réchauffement climatique est en train de
dégeler le pergélisol qui se trouve en
montagne c'est ça qui provoque de
manière accélérée des éboulements dont
la chute du pilier des rues là et
maintenant et toutes les voies mythiques
qui étaient dessus sont partis à tout
jamais a été un exemple très
emblématique
il va malheureusement il en avoir
d'autres
j'en profite pour faire un petit un
petit coup de pub dans les publications
du chiffre Project vous avez un cahier
spécialement montagne alors ça concerne
pas tellement les industriels mais ça
concerne les élus qui a été fait à
destination des élus locaux on a démarré
il y a un an et demi un projet qui
s'appelait résilience des territoires
c'est un projet dans lequel on avait
essayé de regarder qu'est-ce que ça
voulait dire pour un territoire local de
se confronter au double défi du
changement climatique et de la
diminution croissante pardon pour cette
expression un peu malheureuse dimension
croissante
de l'approvisionnement ressources
naturelles donc dit autrement je suis un
élu local d'une commune à l'avenir il va
y avoir moins de pétrole pour se
déplacer et plus de réchauffement
climatique et si je mets les deux dans
la bassine qu'est-ce que ça donne et
qu'est-ce que je peux essayer d'imaginer
comme mesure qui sont à ma main
pour organiser l'avenir de telle sorte
que je navigue au mieux avec ces
contraintes là
et on a fait des cahiers thématiques
dans ce travail là qui concerne des
territoires bien discriminés parce qu'un
territoire de montagne a pas exactement
les mêmes enjeux qu'un territoire
littoral et donc il y a un territoire
parlant un cahier qui concerne les
territoires de montagne voilà c'était
juste ça je voulais dire donc s'il y a
des gens dans la salle qui connaissent
des élus locaux pour leur conseiller
cette lecture normalement il s'ennueront
pas trop
dans les dans ce qui concerne les
territoires de montagne il y a pas que
les histoires de climat il va aussi y
avoir des conséquences de la décrue
énergétique parce que vous êtes bien
placé pour savoir qu'une partie alors
certes l'industrie c'est 25% du PIB de
la Savoie mais sauf erreur de ma part le
tourisme maintenant c'est 50 % et c'est
50% duo tourisme en fait c'est un enfant
du pétrole c'est-à-dire que avant les
moyens de mobilité accessibles pour tous
grâce au pétrole avant l'augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat grâce au pétrole il n'y
avait pas de touristes l'hiver ici enfin
il y avait quelques rentiers qui
venaient prendre l'air à Combloux là
dans le l'espèce de pension de famille
là que vous voyez quand vous montez mais
à part ça il y avait personne donc en
fait vous avez aujourd'hui une manne
économique qui fait aussi vivre la
région qui est une conséquence directe
de l'abondance énergétique qui est le
tourisme d'hiver et aussi le tourisme
d'été du reste quand vous regardez
l'empreinte carbone d'une station de ski
le premier poste de très loin c'est les
déplacements c'est les gens qui viennent
en voiture et pour les stations un
rayonnement international en avion le
deuxième poste c'est le chauffage des
appartements le carburant des dameuses
c'est le troisième l'électricité
l'électricité est remontée mécanique ça
vient très loin derrière c'est
cacahuètes dans l'affaire
les deux premiers postes en fait c'est
des postes fossiles déplacements
chauffage et quand vous êtes à Combloux
un peu les héros des vaches aussi parce
qu'il reste quelques exploitations
agricoles voilà donc il faut manger
moins de reblochon je suis désolé
c'est quand Macron a dit c'est la fin de
l'abondance tout le monde a dit on va
quand même pas bouffer du comté
donc vous avez donc là vous alors c'est
pas vraiment le climat cette histoire là
mais c'est quand même très très lié
comme non passé en fait c'est un facteur
de pression sur le climat qui fait la
richesse une partie de la richesse de la
région aussi encore une fois à savoir le
tourisme permis par 40 millions de
véhicules particuliers dans ce pays et
le fait que les gens aient suffisamment
de pouvoir d'achat pour que on consacre
une fraction de ce qu'on gagne à nos
loisirs chose qui était totalement
impensable il y a un siècle
voilà le changement climatique il est
pas parti pour s'arrêter alors pourquoi
il est pas parti pour s'arrêter parce
que le C alors pour ceux d'entre vous
qui ont des notions de chimie dans la
salle il y en a sûrement quelques-uns
dans l'industrie vous savez
vraisemblablement que le dioxyde de
carbone est un oxyde et donc c'est une
molécule chimique non stable quand vous
mettez une molécule chimiquement stable
dans l'air et bien la molécule reste
comme elle est elle a pas envie de
changer ce qui veut dire que le CO2 une
fois qu'il est mis dans l'air il est
inaltérable il n'a pas de processus
spontané d'épuration pour que le CO2
ressort de l'atmosphère il faut qu'il
revienne au contact du sol ou là il est
soit repris par la végétation avec
l'aide d'un photon avec l'aide de
l'énergie donc c'est un processus
endothermique ça arrive pas tout seul ça
arrive pas la nuit par exemple
ou bien il y a un phénomène de Vasse
communicant entre l'atmosphère et
l'océan qui fait que une partie du CO2
que vous avez mis dans l'air en gros il
y a plus de place dans l'océan dans
l'atmosphère et donc il passe à la
surface de contact entre les deux de
l'atmosphère dans l'océan c'est ce que
les physiciens appellent un équilibrage
de pression partielle
c'est deux phénomènes sont des
phénomènes lents alors la conséquence de
cette affaire c'est que une fois qu'on a
créé un surplus de CO2 dans l'atmosphère
au bout d'un siècle il y en a que la
moitié qui est pardon au bout d'un
siècle après arrêt des émissions donc on
arrête les totalement on crée un surplus
on arrête les émissions d'accord on a
arrêté les émissions on rêve on arrête
les yeux et bien un siècle après arrêt
des émissions il y a la moitié du
surplus de CO2 qui est toujours dans
l'air
Milan après l'arrêt des émissions il y a
un quart du surplus qui est toujours
dans l'air et 10000 ans après arrêt des
émissions il y a toujours 10 à 15 % de
surplus qui est toujours dans l'air ce
qui veut dire que l'état de l'atmosphère
ne reviendra jamais du restant des temps
historiques dans
là où l'atmosphère était avant le début
de leur industriel donc une partie de la
dérive climatique qu'on a mise en route
elle est inarrêtable notamment sur la
hausse du niveau de l'océan sur la fonte
d'une partie de la cryosphère etc quoi
qu'on fasse à partir de maintenant
et par ailleurs le système
sociotechnique qu'on a bâti sur terre il
va pas s'arrêter d'émettre demain matin
parce que le seul cas de figure dans
lequel on aurait ça c'est pandémie
mondial qui est tout au monde guerre
mondiaire etc mais sinon on va pas
passer de 1,2 milliards de véhicules
particuliers qui font notamment vivre
notre hôte de ce soir jusqu'à 0
en une semaine d'accord ça va pas
arriver non on va pas passer de 2200
gigawatts de centrale à charbon dans le
monde à 0 en une semaine d'accord ces
trucs là ne vont pas arriver ce qui veut
dire que des émissions il va continuer à
y en avoir et tant qu'on aimait
l'atmosphère s'enrichit en CO2 tant que
l'atmosphère s'enrichit en CO2 la
température augmente
donc le climat va continuer à changer et
pour vous fixer quelques ordres de
grandeur et je vais finir par ça
aujourd'hui donc le climat s'est
réchauffé d'à peu près 1,1 degré par
rapport à ce qu'on appelle l'air
pré-industriel et plus précisément la
moyenne qu'on a eu sur la planète entre
18 entre 1850 pardon et 1900 donc vous
prenez la totalité de la surface
planétaire et la totalité du temps qui
s'est écoulé entre 1850 et 1900 vous
faites une moyenne de tout ça et bien la
température aujourd'hui c'est déjà
réchauffé d'un peu plus d'un degré par
rapport à cette moyenne alors qu'est-ce
qu'on a un peu plus d'un degré on a les
canicules qu'on connaît aujourd'hui on a
au Pakistan une vague de chaleur qui
dépasse 50 degrés suivi d'inondation qui
ont inondé un septième du pays on a le
Groenland qui a commencé à fondre on a
15% des coraux tropicaux qui sont morts
on a entre 10 et 20% de la forêt
française qui va mourir à climat
constant et alors les arbres ils mettent
des années des dizaines d'années à
mourir mais je veux dire un climat
constant il y a déjà dit à 20% de la
forêt française qui va mourir
on a les sécheresses récurrentes qu'on
commence à connaître et qui devient et
les canicules qu'on commence à connaître
et qui vont devenir rien que dans un
climat qui s'est réchauffé de 1,1 degré
5 fois plus fréquente que ce qu'on avait
sur la deuxième moitié du 19e siècle et
avec une température maximale atteinte
quand elles arrivent qui est de plus de
1,5 degrés au-dessus de ce qu'on avait
dans la deuxième moitié donc rien rien
qu'avec ce 1,1 degré même si on arrêtait
d'enrichir l'atmosphère en CO2
aujourd'hui
on a les précipitations qui ont déjà
commencé à diminuer il vous aura pas
échappé que en France sur les 20
derniers mois on a que trois ou quatre
qui ont connu des précipitations
supérieures à la normale tous les autres
mois ont été déficitaires et l'hiver
qu'on vient de passer a été extrêmement
déficitaire
ce qui veut dire que le niveau des
nappes aujourd'hui est extrêmement bas
par rapport à la normale sur les on va
dire sur les 8/10 du pays actuellement
les nappes sont en dessous de leur
niveau normal alors que la saison de
recharge est quasiment terminée
normalement
voilà tout ça c'est avec 1,1 degrés à 2
degrés alors il y a des choses qui vont
concerner les Alpes et puis il y a des
choses qui vont vous concerner
indirectement même si ça se passe pas
dans les Alpes alors je vais commencer
par un truc qui va vous concerner
indirectement à 2 degrés vous avez à peu
près un milliard d'individus sur terre
tous les gens qui habitent dans la bande
équatoriale qui se mettent à vivre dans
un endroit dans lequel les conditions
externes sont celles d'un hammam en
permanence je sais pas s'il y a déjà des
gens ici qui sont allés dans un hammam
il y a des gens qui sont déjà allés dans
un hammam
oui tout le monde j'en sais rien
bon alors vous êtes capable d'y rester
une demi-heure ou une heure je suis pas
sûr que vous soyez capable d'y rester un
mois d'affilée
et bien là on va avoir affaire dans
toute la bande équatoriale à des zones
dans lesquelles plus d'un jour sur deux
dans l'année vous aurez des températures
une température qui sera supérieure à
celle de votre peau avec un air saturé
en humidité c'est-à-dire que vous
pourrez pas refroidir votre corps par
contact avec l'air et vous pourrez pas
refroidir votre corps on évaporant de
l'eau la transpiration parce que l'air
sera saturé en humidité donc vous
risquez votre peau même pour une
personne jeune et en bonne santé à
sortir dehors
un milliard d'individus à 2 degrés alors
ça concerne pas les Alpes mais ça
concerne un milliard d'individus qui
vont chercher à ailleurs aucun jour ça
concernera la France et donc les Alpes
vous avez également à deux degrés la
totalité des coraux tropicaux qui sont
morts la quasi-totalité des coraux
tropicaux qui sont morts
la moitié voire un peu plus de la forêt
française enfin les espèces actuellement
plantées qui sont mortes
vous avez 20% d'humidité en moins dans
les sols donc vous avez une production
agricole qui va baisser or il faut
savoir que dans les Alpes et ici c'est
là que vous avez le kilométrage le plus
long pour nourrir la population de toute
la France parce que vous êtes loin des
zones agricoles tu restes avant que
l'énergie abondante ne fasse l'industrie
et le tourisme qui font aujourd'hui la
richesse du pays
ici vous aviez des éleveurs de montagnes
et vous en aviez pas beaucoup et c'était
des gens pauvres
donc dans un monde dans lequel il y a
pas de transport longue distance
ici on n'a pas du tout les moyens de
maintenir la population existante vous
êtes beaucoup trop loin des zones
agricoles
dans un monde dans lequel il y a pas de
transport
donc le fait que il y a une pression
croissante sur les dents les agricoles
ça c'est quelque chose qui va se
ressentir partout y compris chez vous
on va avoir une pression croissante
également sur les écosystèmes installés
normal parce que ils sont installés dans
les conditions climatiques historiques
qui étaient très stables depuis 10 ans
et donc voilà si on déstabilise
rapidement les conditions
le niveau de l'eau va continuer à monter
alors ça ça vous concerne pas
directement mais ça peut vous concerner
indirectement si par exemple on commence
à avoir des problèmes de fonctionnement
des ports
tous les gens ici qui ont des
exportations ils sont directement
concernés
si on commence à avoir des problèmes de
dommages aux infrastructures de
transport qui vous relient au port vous
êtes également directement concerné et
dans l'autre sens pour l'importation des
vêtements des chaussures de la
nourriture etc des tables des chaises
essayez aujourd'hui d'acheter une
casserole qui soit pas midi China bon
courage et bien c'est pareil vous êtes
directement concerné donc en fait les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
il faut pas les voir juste comme des
conséquences locales bien sûr la mère de
glace va continuer à fondre et c'est
désagréable bien sûr le glacier des
Bossons va continuer à fondre et c'est
désagréable bien sûr de temps en temps
un morceau de montagne va continuer à
descendre et c'est désagréable mais
c'est pas juste ça les conséquences que
vous allez avoir vous allez également
hériter comme moi comme tout le monde
des conséquences à l'échelle
macroscopique parce que nous vivons
aujourd'hui dans un monde qui est
terriblement interconnecté et
terriblement interdépendant et donc ce
qui se passe à un bout de la planète
peut directement impacter les conditions
de vie de gens de l'autre côté de la
planète je vais revenir à l'automobile
en hommage à notre eau du soir
après le covid alors le covid a rien à
voir avec le changement climatique mais
après le covid il s'est mis à y avoir
une variée une modification des
débouchés avales des gens dans
l'électronique et une partie de la
fabrication d'automobile s'est retrouvé
à l'arrêt tout simplement parce que un
truc qui se passait de l'autre côté de
la planète sur l'allocation des
composants électroniques c'est passer
différemment de ce que ça se passait
avant et là en ce moment il y a des
sécheresses dans des régions de
production en Chine qui engendre des
coupures d'électricité qui engendre des
défauts de production et dans les
chaînes mondialisées ça peut très bien
un jour ou assez rapidement donc le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on est des chaînes
économiques mondialisées font que de
toute façon on ne peut pas se
désintéresser de ce qui se passe au
titre du changement climatique ailleurs
dans le monde parce que c'est
susceptible d'avoir un impact y compris
chez soi et qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
juste l'impact direct du réchauffement
climatique à sa porte
ok vous êtes toujours là super est-ce
que tu veux boire un coup bon très bien
alors tu as répondu à une partie de la
question sur la mondialisation et c'est
très bien est-ce qu'on peut
parler du rapport entre ressources et
l'économie et donc entre les
tensions qui sont en train d'arriver et
tu décris très bien le monde qui arrive
et je te remercie d'ailleurs d'avoir
fait aussi la description des émissions
historiques parce que c'est quand même
important mais donc les ressources
parce que je t'ai parlé des conséquences
du changement climatique mais les
ressources c'est vachement important
aussi puisque l'économie c'est la
transformation avec des ressources et un
peu de gens aussi et on va devoir faire
autrement parce qu'on a tiré sur la
corde faire autrement ou arrêter
certaines activités donc est-ce que d'un
niveau macro et après on descendra dans
nos industries tu peux un peu parler de
de ce qui va pouvoir se transformer et
ce qui va devoir s'arrêter et puis aussi
parfois tu parles de quota de de
en fait de peut-être de partage de ce
qui de ce qui reste finalement bon on
gère la rareté alors
en ce qui concerne les ressources alors
là tous les gens dans la salle qui ont
de l'industrie vous savez très bien que
votre métier consiste à transformer de
la matière donc vous avez un facteur
limitant
pour opérer qui s'appelle votre banquier
vous avez un facteur limitant pour
opérer qui est de trouver les bonnes
compétences mais vous avez également un
facteur limitant pour pouvoir opérer qui
est de trouver la ressource physique à
transformer et si j'élargistre propos à
l'ensemble du système économique en fait
l'ensemble de notre système économique
est une énorme machine est un énorme
système à transformer des ressources
naturelles pour en faire autre chose
vous êtes habillé avec des sciences
naturelles transformées vous êtes assis
sur des ressources naturelles
transformées nous nous trouvons dans un
bâtiment qui est fait de ressources
naturelles transformées vous avez tout à
l'heure mangé parce que notre route est
généreux je crois des ressources
naturelles transformées du reste les ce
que vous allez manger c'est aussi des
ressources fossiles transformées tout à
l'heure vous allez manger du pétrole et
du gaz parce que ce que vous allez
manger aura été cultivé récolté par des
tracteurs qui fonctionnent au pétrole
cultiver récoltés par des tracteurs fake
du charbon puisque c'est de l'acier
c'est fait du charbon et enfin tout ça
aura été fertilisé avec des engrais
azotés qui sont fabriqués avec du gaz
donc tout à l'heure pensez bien quand
vous allez manger vos toasts que vous
êtes en train de manger un truc qui sent
le pétrole le gaz et le charbon
donc en fait notre notre système
économique je le redis est une énorme
machine à transformer des ressources
naturelles et même la partie service
dans cette histoire en fait dépend de
cette transformation des ressources
naturelles vous pouvez pas faire un
service d'enseignement aujourd'hui sans
abattement
sans que les gens viennent dans le
bâtiment pour ça il leur faut des moyens
de transport sans des supports de
formation que ce soit des ordinateurs ou
des livres mieux des livres que des
ordinateurs du reste à mon avis et bien
vous avez besoin de ces de ces
ressources vous avez besoin de chauffage
parce que sinon les élèves l'hiver ils
acceptent pas de venir se peler etc etc
donc en fait quand vous regardez même ou
quand vous allez chez votre coiffeur
chez votre coiffeuse là aussi vous avez
quelqu'un qui ne peut pas opérer sans
ressource naturelle il a enfin il avait
avant des ciseaux maintenant ils ont
tous des tondeuses donc ils ont des
ressources naturelles transformées parce
que si autant d'eux c'est des ressources
vous êtes assis sur un fauteuil c'est
ressources vous êtes dans un local c'est
ressources vous avez des lacs
interventions etc L'Oréal transforme des
ressources enfin bref vous avez même
pour les activités qu'on pense être
dématérialisées parce que c'est des
activités de service en fait vous avez
des ressources absolument partout vous
avez des ressources absolument partout
moi j'ai vécu le passage du papier au
digital dans les factures à l'époque on
appelait ça la dématérialisation
mais cette chère Zazie celle de que
[Musique]
donc notre économie est une énorme
machine à transformer des ressources ce
qui veut dire que pour fonctionner elle
a besoin de ressources merci Monsieur de
Lapalisse et donc on peut très bien
alors jusqu'à maintenant les ressources
n'ont jamais été un facteur limitantes
de manière macroscopique ce qui était
limitant c'était les gens capables
d'opérer la transformation et le capital
qu'on était capable d'installer pour
opérer cette transformation le capital
humain ce qui veut dire que l'économie
vous apprenez à l'école et celle que
j'ai apprise à l'école est une économie
dans laquelle vous avez deux facteurs de
production le travail humain et le
capital humain et le reste on considère
que ça peut pas être un facteur limitant
d'accord donc on a théorisé toutes
l'économie sans considérer que les
ressources naturelles ou l'énergie qui
est une ressource parmi d'autres pouvait
être un facteur limitant
bien évidemment c'est une c'est une hier
qu'on s'est mise parce que les
ressources naturelles peuvent très bien
être un facteur limitant on peut très
bien être un facteur limitant alors
quand on a théorisé l'économie classique
il y a deux siècles il y avait un
milliard de Pékin sur terre il y avait
encore pas de pétrole il y avait un peu
de charbon il y avait essentiellement
une déconnecté une activité agricole etc
l'océan était immense on savait pas que
l'Antarctique existait enfin bref donc
les théoriciens de l'économie classique
de l'époque on dit bon on va se limiter
aux deux trucs qui sont vraiment
limitants maintenant c'est le capital
humain qui était essentiellement la
terre mise en culture et les bons hommes
qui travaillent les ressources
naturelles on va pas s'emmerder parce
que tout ceux d'entre vous qui ont fait
des maths savent qu'une variation
relative d'un stock qui est infini c'est
nul donc on va pas s'emmerder à mettre
des zéros partout comme le savant
cosinus dans ces équations on va se
contenter de ne juste ne pas en tenir
compte
et puis aujourd'hui les ordres de
grandeur ont considérablement changé on
n'est plus un milliard on est 8
milliards et la pression exercée par
individu sur l'environnement sa
prédation de ressources naturelles a été
multipliée par un facteur 10 à 50 en
fonction de la ressource que je regarde
donc on a totalement changé d'ordre de
grandeur et alors que les 13000 km de
diamètre de la planète n'était pas un
problème il y a deux siècles aujourd'hui
c'est le problème on est comment ça va
être un peu à l'étroit dans la boîte de
Pétri donc là la manière dont il faut
bien voir aujourd'hui la dépendance de
l'économie hors-source naturelle c'est
avec des indicateurs physiques parce que
c'est pas dans les indicateurs
économiques votre compte de résultat
vous dit pas quel est votre dépendance
physique surnaturel donc vous êtes
obligé d'avoir des comptabilités
séparées pour ça vous êtes obligé
d'avoir une comptabilité cuivre une
comptabilité gaz à effet de serre une
comptabilité éteint une comptabilité or
etc si vous voulez bien comprendre quel
est votre dépendance en source naturelle
et à quelle distance vous êtes de la
contrainte qui va s'appliquer parce que
là il y a quelque chose que vous allez
facilement comprendre toute ressource
naturelle non renouvelable le minerai de
cuivre l'or minerai de fer le pétrole
etc vous ne pouvez pas c'est
mathématiquement démontrable avoir un
prélèvement éternellement croissant qui
en provient ni même un prélèvement
éternellement constant
c'est formellement interdit c'est un
terme de maths que j'ai encore démontré
ce qui veut dire qu'à partir du moment
où vous tapez dans un stock de
ressources non renouvelables vous pouvez
mathématiquement démontrer qu'il arrive
un moment où le flux en provenance de ce
stock devient structurellement
décroissant
donc ça veut dire qu'il y en a plus
assez pour tout le monde si tout le
monde continue à en vouloir autant
alors on commence c'est les pics de
production pour les ressources non
renouvelables on commence à y arriver
pour un certain nombre de ressources
alors pour le pétrole conventionnel par
exemple tout ce qui n'est pas les
habitudes lumineux et le chez loy on va
passer en 2008
pour le pétrole tout pétrole confondu y
compris avec le Sheller soit on l'a
passé en 2018 soit on va le passer dans
les années qui vient mais enfin en gros
c'est en cours quoi
pour le cuivre l'Agence internationale
de l'énergie a dit il y a maintenant un
an alors en général laieu quand ils
envoient des alertes c'est la note de
bas de page de page 136 du rapport que
personne ne lit mais enfin si vous si
vous êtes attentif aux documents vous
l'avez l'alerte ils ont dit que les
mines de cuivre actuellement en
fonctionnement ou en développement dans
le monde en développant c'est que les
infrastructures de production sont en
cours de construction allez passer leur
pic dans les deux ans qui viennent
enfin c'est dans pas longtemps quoi
et pour faire une nouvelle mine entre le
moment où vous le décidez et le moment
où la mine commence à fonctionner il
faut 20 ans c'est l'ordre de grandeur
dans l'industrie minière
donc là vous voyez une ressource par
exemple dans l'industrie se sert de
manière significative en particulier
pour les gens qui sont dans tout ce qui
est électrique sur lequel il devrait se
mettre à y avoir des trucs bizarroïdes
sur les prix dans pas très très
longtemps donc les ressources naturales
on a d'autres ressources naturelles qui
n'ont ces qui nous sont nécessaires par
exemple l'espace l'espace est une
ressource qui est suffisamment précieuse
pour que la France est votée une loi
zéro artificialisation nette il y a pas
longtemps
voilà donc en fait toutes l'économie
fonctionne avec en transformant des
ressources naturelles
et il est important si on veut avoir
aujourd'hui une vision prospective de
son activité quel que soit l'activité
qu'on est
d'essayer de comprendre à quelle
distance on est de la contrainte en
fonction des ressources qu'on utilise
un média utilise je le répète l'électro
enfin les outils électroniques les
écrans qu'il y a dans le studio d'à côté
les ordinateurs etc 40 métaux différents
qu'on a là-dedans alors certes vous
pouvez avoir des petites substitutions
entre métaux mais il y en a certains qui
ont des propriétés très particulières
incidemment les terres ce qu'on appelle
les terres rares en fait c'est pas des
terres c'est des métaux les terres rares
c'est des métaux chimiquement
et donc dans les ordinateurs une partie
des métaux sont des sont des terres
rares
vous avez donc un et bien l'activité
aujourd'hui de radio Mont-Blanc et de
télé Mont-Blanc on ne pourrait plus la
continuer si tout d'un coup il devient
impossible d'acheter des équipements
électroniques
au business
dans ces équipements électroniques je le
redis vous avez des métaux votre compte
en banque aujourd'hui c'est des métaux
vous avez tout un compte en banque dans
vos entreprises
à moins que vous n'ayez que des
mallettes de billets parce qu'on n'est
pas loin de Genève non
et bien votre compte en banque
aujourd'hui
c'est des métaux et des électrons
c'est grâce à ça qu'on peut faire de la
création monétaire autant qu'on veut à
l'époque où la monnaie était indexée sur
l'or accroche-toi pour faire ce genre de
trucs
on était obligé d'avoir autant d'heures
qu'on crée de monnaie bon le fait de
aujourd'hui la monnaie c'est totalement
virtuelle ça c'est des électrons et des
métaux sur des ordinateurs voilà c'est
des ordinateurs et des
donc des dynamiciens du MIT system
pardon du MIT qui ont fait un modèle
pour regarder où pouvait aller
l'activité économique et humaine dans un
monde fini qui recherchait la croissance
perpétuelle qui est très exactement ce
qu'on est en train de faire en ce moment
et la conclusion à laquelle ils étaient
arrivés c'est que le système
s'effondrera sur lui-même faute de
ressources ou faute d'environnement sain
dans le courant du 21e siècle
et quand des chercheurs ont regardé si
sur les indicateurs qu'il suivait alors
qui était des indicateurs très
macroscopiques par exemple ils avaient
un seul indicateur pour les ressources
non renouvelables une seule variable
rappelez-vous que en 1972 il y a des
Belges dans la salle
l'informatique était pas ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui donc on n'était pas capable
de faire des modèles avec 50 variables
différentes mais le truc est assez
robuste et en particulier si vous
considérez que un bon proxy pour les
ressources naturelles non renouvelables
en fait c'est l'énergie nécessaire à les
extraire donc en fait que l'énergie tout
court est un bon proxy pour les
ressources leur modèle fonctionne assez
bien et aujourd'hui on est à peu près
entrac sur là où il pensait que on
devait aller et effectivement par
exemple même sans se préoccuper du
climat le pic pétrole il est proche le
pigaz il est il va suivre de 10 ou 20
ans même sans se préoccuper du climat
pour des raisons géologiques parce qu'il
faut des centaines de millions d'années
pour faire du pétrole et du gaz
une fois qu'on commencera à avoir de
moins en moins d'énergie on aura de
moins en moins de métaux parce que la
teneur en métal des minerais n'arrête
pas de baisser et donc il faut de plus
en plus d'énergie pour extraire une
tonne de métal du minerai
la teneur en cuivre des minerais qu'il y
avait en Espagne à Rio Tinto la rivière
rouge
doré orange enfin bref qui est du reste
cette rivière qui a donné son nom à la
compagnie minière éponyme il y a une
grosse compagnie minière dans le monde
aujourd'hui qui s'appelle Riot Tinto
et bien la teneur en cuivre de ce
minerai se baladait aux alentours de 15%
. les mines les vieilles mines que vous
avez dans les Alpes il y avait des mines
dans les Alpes qui étaient exploités il
y a un siècle c'est pareil il y a un
siècle en exploitait des mines avec des
teneurs en métal qui étaient de entre 5
et 10%. la teneur moyenne en cuivre
aujourd'hui des mines qu'on exploite
dans le monde c'est 0,4%
d'accord c'était 15% 0,4 c'est évident
que sans énorme machines et sans plein
d'énergie on ne sait pas exploiter ce
genre de choses donc vous avez besoin de
beaucoup d'énergie aujourd'hui pour
extraire des métaux de la croûte
terrestre donc quand on va commencer à
passer le pic des énergies faciles et en
particulier le pic du pétrole
vraisemblablement que ça va avec un
décalage que je ne connais pas parce que
dans les en train de vivre une
expérience inédite mettre une contrainte
globale sur la quantité de ressources
naturelles disponibles non renouvelable
les ressources renouvelables là on a
l'effondrement des écosystèmes c'est un
autre problème mais globalement on va
avoir une diminution donc ça veut dire
et c'est pas le prix actuel de la
ressource parce que j'ai un compte de
résultat carbone 4 comme vous donc c'est
à peu près ce que c'est je sais même ce
que c'est qu'une dotation aux
amortissements et bien c'est pas le prix
actuel de ce que vous achetez qui vous
donne la moindre indication sur la
quantité dont vous disposerez dans 10 ou
20 ans
ça ne vous dit rien là-dessus absolument
rien si vous voulez savoir de quelle
quantité vous pouvez éventuellement
disposer dans 10 ou 20 ans vous êtes
obligé de faire une analyse prospective
sur la ressource physique elle-même
vous pouvez pas vous contenter des prix
actuels il ne vous dit rien
il ne vous disent strictement rien le
prix du gaz il y a un siècle il y a un
an et demi pardon ne vous dit pas
combien on en aura dans deux ans
il vous le dit pas
voilà
alors on a deux manières de gérer la
rareté
on a par les limitations quantitatives
les quotas par exemple les tickets de
rationnement qu'on avait pendant la
guerre enfin pas moi du reste et pas
vous nos parents et grands-parents et on
a parlé de prix
donc par exemple si j'ai moins d'essence
j'ai deux manières de gérer le problème
je vais payer le lit de plus cher puis
ceux qu'on les moyens en achète et ceux
qui n'ont pas les moyens d'enchètent pas
ou bien je dis chacun riche ou pauvre
aura 18 par semaine et démerdez-vous
avec ça
la France historiquement préfère de très
loin la gestion égalitaire c'est-à-dire
par les quotas on l'a bien vu au moment
du covid on vous a pas dit il y a un
passe pour sortir dehors ça vaut 2000
euros l'heure d'accord on a dit riche ou
pauvre vous aurez une heure par jour
pour aller faire vos besoins comme les
chiens pour aller sortir pas les mêmes
besoins et puis et puis c'est comme ça
voilà alors il se trouve que les riches
ils étaient dans des endroits un peu
ouvert un peu mieux lotis quand même que
les pauvres qui étaient dans les bars
HLM à Garges-lès-Gonesse mais en
attendant il y a quand même eu un
traitement un peu égalitaire qui était
que voilà le français préférée en
général ce genre de truc alors en
matière de
climat par exemple il y a les deux
écoles qui s'affrontent donc il y a
l'école des taxes les gens qui disent
faut une taxe carbone j'en ai fait
partie j'en suis un peu revenu je peux
vous expliquer pourquoi
j'en suis pas complètement revenu mais
un peu
et puis il y a les gens qui disent il
faut limiter par les quantités et ça
c'est l'école européenne les quotas
d'émissions qu'on a commencé à appliquer
alors en fait aucun des deux systèmes
n'est parfait le quota il a le mérite si
il est efficace de vous garantir la
quantité qui sera émise
si vraiment on s'y tiens si on crée pas
derrière des quotas gratuits des quotas
supplémentaires des machins parce que
les gens viennent pleurer en disant
vraiment je vais pas y arriver à dire si
tu vas pas y arriver alors quand même je
te file un peu
par contre il a un gros inconvénient
c'est qu'il ne dit pas à l'avance quel
est son prix
c'est un marché et donc ça veut dire que
les gens qui sont dans la salle ils
peuvent pas calibrer leurs
investissements
en faisant un arbitrage entre ce que ça
me coûte de pas faire l'investissement
est-ce que ça me coûte de faire
l'investissement
pour ça il faut un signal prix
prévisible et donc il faut une taxe
donc dans le B2B en fait la taxe c'est
plutôt mieux parce qu'en plus les gens
qui sont dans la salle sauf ceux qui
sont dans des ttpe ils ont les moyens
d'embaucher quelques consultants pas
nécessairement une armée mais quelques
consultants armés de leur table leur
Excel qui vont commencer à faire des tas
de savants calculs en disant à très
exactement 53,2 euros la tonne de CO2
tel investissement sur telle ligne ça
vaut le coup de le faire tel switch dans
les approvisionnements ça vaut le coup
de le faire telle modification de la
logistique ça vaut le coup de la faire
le particulier j'avais il va faire appel
à un consultant avec son tableur Excel
consultant du particulier c'est lui-même
voilà et en général il fait pas de
calcul sur Excel donc il ne sait pas le
particulier comment est-ce qu'il
s'organise si la taxe carbone monte à 30
40 50 100 200 300 euros la taille c'est
absolument pas ce genre de truc
un effet sur ses courses mais ça va
avoir un effet sur ce qu'il va faire
mais ça il sait pas donc c'est pour ça
que la taxe je pense que c'est un très
bon outil dans le milieu B2B
les Anglais du reste on éradiquer le
charbon dans leur production électrique
si vous voulez voir un pays qui a été
efficace sur la gestion de la
décarbonation de son électricité ne
regardez pas l'Allemagne regardez la
Grande-Bretagne si on parlait tout à
l'heure des défaillances des médias les
médias nous ont rebattu les oreilles
avec l'Allemagne c'est pas du tout
l'Allemagne qu'il faut regarder c'est la
Grande-Bretagne la Grande-Bretagne c'est
quasiment totalement débarrassé de son
charbon dans la production électrique en
20 ans
20 ans ils ont remplacé ça par de
l'éolien et du gaz ils sont en train de
repartir à fond dans le nucléaire donc
en fait quand vous regardez un truc un
peu cohérent sur la décarbonation de
l'électricité la Grande-Bretagne est un
exemple beaucoup plus intéressant que
l'Allemagne
et ils ont fait ça avec une taxe et ils
ont dit ça sera 100 euros la tote de CO2
sur la production électrique et donc le
charbon était absolument plus
concurrentiel et donc ils ont basculé
alors ils avaient de gaz ils étaient
producteurs de gaz qui est intéressant
quand même mais ils ont ils ont basculé
très très vite
chez les particuliers c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué parce que le particulier
il sait pas se projeter à 10 ans et puis
par ailleurs il ne sait pas planifié ces
investissements ou mal planifier ses
investissements il est dans un dialogue
avec ses fournisseurs dans lequel il est
tout petit face à des gros fournisseurs
qui fournissent pour plein de gens il a
beaucoup de mal à organiser de sa propre
veille concurrentielle c'est très
difficile voilà il a pas confiance dans
les artisans il sait pas etc il sait pas
comment faire la qu'on fait la
différence entre un bon plombier un
mauvais plombier un bon maçon un mauvais
maçon enfin etc donc le particulier il
faut lui dire quoi faire c'est beaucoup
mieux donc avec le particulier c'est la
réglementation qu'il faut agir qu'il
faut qu'il faut actionner pour
l'essentiel donc par exemple dire aux
particuliers à partir de maintenant tu
as plus le droit de remplacer une
chaudière à fioul par une chaudière à
fioul c'est une très bonne mesure dire
aux particuliers la prochaine fois que
ta chaudière à gaz tombera en panne en
te prévient faudra que tu la remplaces
par une pompe à chaleur c'est une très
bonne mesure il faut pas dire aux
particuliers le gaz va de côté de plus
en plus cher d'accord parce que
particulier c'est pas gérer ça et le
gilet jaune il faut pas lui dire
l'essence va te coûter de plus en plus
cher ou en tout cas ça peut pas être la
mesure principale
il faut lui dire
tu gagnes moins de 1500 euros par mois
on va te payer la moitié d'une voiture
électrique tu gagnes plus c'est pour tes
pieds enfin voilà il faut il faut dire
quelque chose qui est
qui décrit la mesure
voilà il faut il faut avoir une
politique de l'offre j'ai envie de dire
beaucoup plus qu'une voilà
accompagnement alors et de
l'accompagnement et là alors la taxe
peut être une mesure anti effet rebond
intéressante par exemple s'il y a plein
de gens qui passent à la voiture
électrique qu'on a toujours autant de
pétrole en France il faudra beaucoup
moins cher et à ce moment il faut pas
que les autres se mettent à s'engager
bon donc la taxe peut être une très
bonne mesure d'accompagnement elle a un
gros inconvénient par ailleurs la taxe
c'est que elle rend l'état dépendant de
l'assiette qu'il devrait faire
disparaître
je m'explique
si je taxe les sens pour faire
disparaître les sens
je crée une recette fiscale pour l'État
qui a vocation a disparaître
puisqu'il y aura plus d'essence d'accord
donc la taxe qui a pour vocation de tuer
l'assiette sur laquelle elle est assise
c'est un truc que l'État ne sait pas
manipuler parce qu'une fois que il
empoche 50 milliards d'euros de TICPE
par an
il sait pas comment faire ça donc en
fait la fiscalité carbone qui devient
une fiscalité
principale très importante devient une
fiscalité de rente
et à ce moment ça devient extrêmement
difficile d'avoir des politiques
publiques ambitieuses
qui vise à supprimer l'assiette générant
la rente
donc
il faut aussi être qui reste ça veut
dire que dès lors qu'on met en place une
taxe carbone pour supprimer des
émissions il faut dès la conception même
de la taxe savoir comment on fera une
fois qu'elle sera plus là
c'est un peu comme vous si vous avez des
recettes transitoires faites un gros
coup d'accord vous avez une activité
récurrente puis un jour on vous propose
un truc c'est le gros coup en dehors de
votre activité récurrente de compter
surtout pas dessus pour financer votre
activité récurrente d'accord sinon vous
allez au casse-pipe de manière
absolument certaine et bah c'est un peu
quand même ce qu'on est tenté de faire
avec la taxe carbone si ça devient une
taxe importante au niveau au niveau de
l'État il faut faire derrière une un
switch voilà donc ça c'est pas c'est pas
un instrument miraculeux genre et alors
la dernière raison pour laquelle on a
beaucoup parlé de taxe carbone là ça va
vous faire rigoler c'est que c'est le
seul truc que les économistes ça
manipuler
un économiste un macroéconomiste ne sait
pas donner à manger à son modèle une
limitation de vitesse qui va faire
baisser la consommation des voitures il
ne sait pas donner à manger à son modèle
d'une ZFE il ne sait pas donner à manger
à son modèle le fait que on oblige les
gens à remplacer les chaudières à fioul
par des pompes à chaleur parce que dans
son modèle tout ce qui s'est géré c'est
des élasticités prévues et donc pour ça
il a besoin d'un prix
donc tous les économistes que vous
entendrez s'exprimer sur la question ne
vont tous vous parler que de taxe
carbone
pour une seule raison c'est que si on
parle pas de taxe carbone ils sont au
chômage
on peut plus rien faire de leurs outils
donc il faut subventionner les
économistes pour qu'il fasse autre chose
de leur temps plutôt que nous venons des
modèles pareil exactement donc la seule
raison pour laquelle il parle que de
taxe carbone et j'insiste c'est parce
que ils ne savent gérer que des chocs de
prix dans les modèles qu'ils utilisent
ils ne savent pas gérer des chocs
réglementaires
les modèles sont pas faits pour ça donc
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles le
débat le débat dans le monde économique
se focalise là-dessus et je me suis fait
avoir comme tout le monde au sens où
alors encore une fois je reste partisan
de la tasse carbone dans un certain
nombre d'usages discriminés je considère
pas du tout que ce soit un outil inutile
en tant que tel par contre je pense que
c'est pas un outil universel comme ce
que j'ai cru à un moment alors ça aurait
pu être un outil universel si on a vu
deux siècles devant nous
quand vous regardez ce qui s'est passé
au niveau de la diésalisation du parc en
France c'est un processus qui a pris 40
ans donc si on avait deux siècles devant
nous ça serait pas là pour le coup ça
serait pas gênant d'avoir une taxe
carbone on augmente un peu tous les ans
l'état tous les ans se dit je vais
augmenter un peu d'autres impôts bref
on peut y arriver mais si on a 30 ans
devant nous ça peut plus être
l'instrument principal ok alors donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut gérer
réglementairement par les quantités
de se faire limiter aussi donc accepter
des limites
ça
tombe pour reprendre l'exemple de
l'automobile ça veut dire limiter les
poids ça veut dire limiter les vitesses
maximales ça veut dire limiter les
puissances ça veut dire limiter les
consommations donc les émissions au pot
d'échappement voilà ça veut dire limiter
tous ces trucs là
ok très bien alors on va passer aux
questions ind
ustrielles disons qu'il y a beaucoup de
questions ou alors je vais essayer de
les de les réunir parce que je pense
qu'on est tous en train de boire tes
paroles
j'ai en train de déraper au niveau du
temps
il paraît qu'on dit à minuit c'est comme
ça ouais alors j'ai juste une question
pour la salle pour pour vous remotiver
parce que quand même j'ai pas vous mais
moi j'ai pris une claque et pourtant la
plupart des trucs je les sais mais quand
on se les redit voilà est-ce que vous
avez une idée de la balance commerciale
française pour les biens industriels
parce que maintenant on passe on passe
au sujet industrie l'industrie son signe
ou soit montant
vous êtes sur la piste sensible ou son
montant les deux mon général tu sais toi
ou pas pour les biens industriels
mais alors de combien exactement je peux
pas quelques dizaines de milliards
d'euros
35 milliards mais vous êtes dans les
bons ordres de grandeur et vous avez le
bon signe devant le chiffre de déficit
donc annuel malgré la chimie l'acide
urgique et exporte la moitié de leur
production donc donc quand même je
voulais vous dire que dans la région
vous êtes plutôt pas mal question
industrie appliquée au territoire ici en
particulier
est-ce qu'on peut travailler à l'échelle
du territoire dans un monde mondialisé
là attendez j'essaye de réunir deux
questions quand même truc la réponse
acrobatique la réponse est non la
réponse est non il y a pas mais non il y
a pas une il y a pas une mine alors je
vais être un peu plus précis
la réponse initiale et non est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'on peut rien faire non mais
la réponse ils tiennent non je vais vous
donner un exemple aujourd'hui vous
n'avez en ce qui concerne l'acier vous
n'avez pas une mine de fer sur le
territoire tu vois si vous n'avez pas un
haut fourneau ni à laminoir sur le
territoire pardon
est-ce que je sais même pas est-ce que
vous avez un four électrique ici
d'accord donc vous avez quand même un
four électrique
mais il y a pas de au fond d'eau on est
bien d'accord voilà donc là vous avez
pas de ressources primaire sur le
territoire vous pouvez vous organiser
pour avoir une ressource secondaire à
condition de recycler sur le territoire
les ferrailles du territoire
alors je sais pas si le four électrique
il recycle les voitures intégralement ou
si il faut déjà avoir fait le tri à
l'amant etc bon bref il y a un certain
nombre tout ce qui est issu de la chimie
organique vous êtes totalement dépendant
de la mondialisation puisque la chimie
organique c'est du pétrole et du gaz et
là je suis raisonnablement sûr qu'il y a
pas un seul puit de pétrole ici et pas
un seul puit de gaz
donc est-ce que on peut ici
s'abstraire de la mondialisation pour
faire tourner l'économie telle qu'elle
se présente non parce que je pense pas
qu'il y ait un seul industriel dans la
salle qui n'est pas un bout de plastique
ou dans les machines industrielles qui
l'utilisent ou dans les matières qu'il
traite et puis il y a de l'export d'ici
en plus alors ça c'est pour les recettes
c'est la dépendance économique mais là
je parlais déjà de la dépendance matière
l'essentiel voilà je suis pas sûr que
vous pourriez fonctionner ici sans
camion et les camions ils sont fabriqués
à nouveau avec de l'acier qui vient pas
d'ici et ils utilisent du pétrole qui
vient pas d'ici donc est-ce que on peut
faire fonctionner l'économie du
territoire en s'abstrayant de la
s'extrayant de la mondialisation la
réponse est non
puis par ailleurs vous mangez pas ici si
vous êtes juste sur l'économie locale
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
l'idée d'autonomie des territoires est
une idée qui me sort par les trous de
nez parce que ça n'a aucune espèce de
réalité et ça n'aura jamais aucune
espèce de réalité voilà et quand les
quand les élus locaux qui veulent un peu
bomber le torse parle d'autonomie
énergétique en général déjà il se limite
à l'électricité et il dit ça quand ils
ont une éolienne dans un champ et qu'ils
ont 300 habitants sur la commune qui
font plus et moins sur l'année on dirait
ça y est c'est bon
n'importe quoi
donc et l'autonomie par ailleurs c'est
l'absence de communication entre les
individus et donc un jour ou l'autre
c'est la guerre
donc on a aucun intérêt à être autodome
aucun ce qui est intéressant c'est
d'organiser sa dépendance avec des gens
qu'on aime bien
donc idéalement donc idéalement voilà
c'est comme dans un couple donc
idéalement avec des gens qui ont
symétriquement besoin de soi et avec qui
on s'entend bien donc l'idée la
résilience c'est pour ça qu'on a appelé
notre travail aussi project résiliente
la résilience pour nous c'est ça c'est à
dire se mettre à dépendre de gens qui
vont pas vous claquer dans les doigts
qui ne vont pas eux-mêmes avoir des
problèmes d'approvisionnement pour ce
qui vous intéresse et qui ont besoin de
vous comme vous avez besoin d'eux voilà
ça c'est quelque chose qui est
intéressant mais l'idée alors c'est
clair que de relocaliser une partie ça
peut pas faire de mal ça supprime pas
totalement
parce qu'aujourd'hui le curseur est allé
beaucoup trop loin sur la longueur des
chaînes de valeur et la fraction de ce
qui nous est nécessaire pour vivre qui
dont la fabrication nous échappe
totalement sur laquelle on a absolument
zéro reprise donc l'idée qu'on revienne
à une fraction plus locale ça c'est
quelque chose qui est pertinent et c'est
quelque chose qui est en phase avec le
fait que les échanges c'est de l'énergie
et dans un monde avec moins d'énergie il
y aura moins d'échange
Yves Cochet avait une maxime que je
trouvais pas mal qui a dit le pétrole ça
nous a permis d'aller plus vite plus
loin moins cher et après la décrue
pétrolière on va aller moins loin moins
vite et pour plus cher
c'est exactement ça bon c'est un assez
bon résumé ça veut pas dire qu'on va
plus nulle part du reste il y avait des
commerçants il m'a mémoire à Simon ma
connaissance de l'histoire de la région
est bonne la Savoie a produit des
commerçants qui se sont expatriés dans
le monde entier à l'époque où il
marchait à pied bon et où il y avait de
la marine à voile donc ça veut pas dire
que avec moi d'énergie on va pas avoir
d'échange du tout mais la part de ces
échanges va devenir plus modeste du
reste à commencer quand vous regardez la
part des échanges mondiaux dans le PIB
mondial c'était de 20 ou 25% en 1970
c'est monté à 60% en 2008 et depuis 2008
qui est comme par hasard le pic de
production du pétrole conventionnel ça
commence à commencer à redescendre et
aujourd'hui c'est à 55
bon signe je sais pas parce que du coup
on a plus de paracétamol pour enfants
mais en tout cas
c'est un signe et on va devoir se
relocaliser alors sur relocaliser ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que dans les
métiers qui sont les vôtres qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait avec la mondialisation et
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait avec l'abondance
énergétique on a fait des tas d'unités
extrêmement spécialisés sur des étapes
de fabrication
loin les unes des autres
avec des gens dont les compétences sont
très pointues sur l'étape de
spécialisation dans laquelle il
travaille et qui dès qu'il faut changer
d'étapes de d'étapes de fabrication sont
déjà un peu largués voir complètement
largué
à l'époque mon grand-père que je n'ai
jamais connu parce que il est mort en
déportation avait une petite usine de
fabrication et de réparation de postes
de radio à Paris ils étaient 20 et à 20
ils arrivaient à fabriquer à réparer des
postes de radio
donc ce vers quoi on va avec le
raccourcissement des chaînes de valeur
c'est une plus grande polyvalence des
unités de fabrication
une augmentation des coûts une des
spécialisation des unités et une
diminution de la variété des gammes
c'est vers ça qu'on va parce que c'est
en tendance l'exact inverse qu'on a eu
avec l'abondance énergétique donc avec
la sobriété énergétique qu'on aura de
Gréoux de force pour des raisons de
climat pour des raisons d'épuisement des
combustibles fossiles et bien nous
allons faire le chemin dans l'autre sens
et donc relocaliser réindustrialiser la
France si on est intelligent ça se fait
avec ce cahier des charges là d'accord
par ailleurs rien industrialiser la
France il y a un tout petit sujet c'est
qu'une bonne partie des matières
premières on les a plus du tout alors il
y a encore un peu de bauxite en France
il y a du lithium il y a encore quelques
minutes de faire qu'on pourrait réouvrir
avec des teneurs qui sont pas terribles
et reste 3 m de charbon mais globalement
quand même on n'est pas du tout au
niveau des volumes qu'on manipule
aujourd'hui sur la quantité d'objets
manufacturés qu'on utilise en France
donc on va avoir quand même une
diminution des volumes
et une augmentation des prix unitaires
encore une fois en termes réel il va
falloir travailler plus d'heures pour se
payer un objet donné
du coup on va augmenter les services de
réparation alors dans tout ce que je
vous raconte vous voyez que il y a de la
prise pour de l'action locale par
exemple commencer à faire des trucs
réutilisables ou réparables ça c'est
quelque chose qui peut s'organiser et
donc réciter les ferrailles pour c'est
quelque chose qui peut s'organiser à
l'échelle d'un territoire
et notamment tout ce qui est
réutilisation j'ai acheté il y a pas
très longtemps un truc qui doit être
fabriqué dans le coin du reste un
pantalon lagopède pour ceux d'entre vous
qui font du ski de randonnée c'est fait
avec des bouteilles de plastique
recyclées donc c'est l'instant pub et
avec du coton recyclé donc en fait ils
prennent des vieux bout de coton il
détrit des tricote tout ils refont le
fil il rôtissent etc et c'est comme ça
qu'ils font les doublures bon ben voilà
ça c'est une forme c'est une forme alors
c'est pas circulaire à l'échelle du
territoire c'est circulaire à l'échelle
de l'Europe bon mais voilà un exemple
évidemment c'est pas le même prix
j'aurais été acheté le truc chez
Décathlon savoir à côté 50 balles je
l'ai payé 400 bon moi j'ai les moyens
donc je le fais mais voilà mais c'est
emblématique à mon avis de la tendance
lourde qui va être celle vers laquelle
on se dirige alors là j'ai parlé de
l'industrie on pourrait parler d'autres
mesures qui sont à la main du territoire
qui sont des mesures d'économie
par exemple les élus locaux ils ont la
main sur les limitations de vitesse ils
ont la main sur la voir moi un truc pour
lequel je milite aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
devrait plus y avoir une opération de
BTP sur la voirie pour voiture sans
qu'on rajoute des infrastructures
cyclables d'accord on passe pas une
commande de BTP sans qu'on rajoute de
quoi mettre la possibilité pour les
vélos de circuler en voirie séparer des
voitures
vous faites un truc comme ça
progressivement vous avez un territoire
qui devient un peu moins dépendant des
combustibles fossiles
un peu moins
et puis maintenant que on a d'excellents
moteurs électriques autre minute de pub
que on a des vélos à assistance
électrique même les côtes c'est plus des
sujets
on voit aujourd'hui des gens qu'on
n'aurait jamais imaginé sur un vélo il y
a 20 ans se déplacer à vélo électrique
et ils ont pas l'air de souffrir autre
mesure donc c'est quelque chose qui peut
être parfaitement organisée donc il y a
des mesures comme ça qui peuvent être
faites à l'échelle du territoire qui
sont des mesures de moindre dépendance à
l'égard de ce qui vient de loin du
territoire je vais finir par une
recommandation qui vous étonnera pas
puisque dans l'industrie en général on a
des bureaux d'études c'est-à-dire des
gens qui réfléchissent ça comment s'y
prendre dans un cadre donné et bien avec
les territoires il faut faire exactement
pareil c'est à dire comment s'y prendre
dans un cadre donné et donc la première
recommandation du rapport résilience des
territoires du chiffre project c'était
messieurs les élus locaux et Madame les
élus locaux les élus locales pardon
mettez 1% du budget de la collectivité
locale dans la formation et
l'acquisition d'informations
pour que vous soyez capable de savoir
dans quelle direction vous allez devoir
agir parce que on va pas avoir la
possibilité de faire 50 fois et c'est
erreur avec le temps qu'il nous reste
et vous êtes bien placé pour savoir dans
l'industrie que quand on a pas 50 fois
la possibilité de faire essai erreur il
vaut mieux pas se planter du premier
coup donc c'est pas une mauvaise idée de
mettre un peu d'argent au début pour
savoir quoi faire exactement avant de se
lancer
voilà
alors je pense que le temps avance donc
je voulais faire un truc rigolo je
voulais te dire que c'était mes
questions et tu choisis non mais ça peut
être sympa ou alors on fait voter le
public
tu nous connais j'avais une question sur
les emplois on nous dit 85 % des emplois
en 2030 n'existent pas encore voilà mais
comment passer des produits au service
j'y crois pas une seconde ça 85 % des
emplois de 2030 existent aujourd'hui
simplement il s'exerceront pas
nécessairement exactement dans les mêmes
conditions et ça sera pas exactement les
mêmes volumes oui on est d'accord c'est
pas tous les trucs rapport à l'IA aux
nouvelles technologies ok on est on est
d'accord et du coup il faut des
formations aussi pour
peut-être qu'on peut passer cette
question parce que les gens ont qu'à
acheter le PTF parce que tout le volet
formation éducation etc et
je vais quand même dire un mot c'est
majeur la formation
tout à fait c'est pour ça que je voulais
et c'est un des angles morts souvent des
politiques publiques en France je vais
prendre un exemple qui est la rénovation
des logements
est-ce que vous pouvez me dire quelle
est la première fois où vous avez
entendu un politique dans ce pays dire
il faut un million de logements rénovés
par an
oui c'est ça
c'était au moins Hollande c'était au
moins c'était au moins il y a 10 ans
et peut-être même avant
ils sont où le mais ils sont toujours
pas là pourquoi ils sont toujours pas là
parce que quand on a dit il va falloir
rénover un million de logements il y a
un des trucs auxquels on sait pas
intéressé c'est comment est-ce qu'on
fait venir de 100 ou 300 000 artisans du
bâtiment supplémentaire
tout d'un coup exactement alors pas tout
d'un coup mais même au fur et à mesure
comment on les fait venir comment on les
fait venir quand l'éducation nationale
tient au gamin le discours qui est cité
bon tirer à la fac et cité naze tirant
en bac pro comment on les trouve comment
on les trouve quand aujourd'hui alors on
n'est pas dans la rénovation là on n'est
pas dans l'artisanat mais même une boîte
comme Bouygues où les gens rentrent à
2500 balles par mois
ils arrivent pas à trouver de français à
embaucher pour les métiers de la
construction comme on les trouve bon
donc vous voyez bien qu'il y a un sujet
compétent alors le sujet compétence il
va être la formation il va avec les
statut il va avec les sujets diplômes de
reconnaissance de de statut social etc
aller chez notre voisin en Suisse alors
ils ont pas que des mallettes de billets
ils ont aussi un système dans lequel
l'essentiel de l'acquisition d'un métier
se fait par la voie professionnelle
et bien vous n'avez pas ce que vous avez
en France c'est-à-dire cette espèce
d'aristocratie des métiers en tout cas
c'est beaucoup moins prononcé et quand
vous discutez avec quelqu'un dans la rue
vous êtes infoutu de savoir s'il est
boulanger plombier ou prof d'université
vraiment
[Musique]
et je pense qu'en France donc on a un
vrai sujet sur la manière dont on gère
la formation à la fois initiale et
continue et que c'est un vrai angle mort
des politiques publiques alors c'est
beaucoup moins un angle mort dans les
entreprises parce que les entreprises
savent qu'il y a des sujets de formation
et que c'est des trucs importants pour
elle mais par contre dans les politiques
publiques c'est vraiment un truc sur
lequel on fait pas du tout assez
attention et je trouve qu'on gère ça de
manière pas du tout structurée et pas du
tout coordonné avec les ambitions
économiques industrielles et
environnementales qu'on se donne par
ailleurs
ok je pense que tu vas enfin j'ai cru
comprendre que tu allais rencontrer des
élus donc je pense que c'est un bon
message il me semble que la régie me dit
que
que ça va waouh ok encore une question
géniale
j'hésite du coup
comment le public avec un vecteur de un
vecteur de planification oui absolument
public alors j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure dans le BTP l'essentiel de la
clientèle du BTP c'est de la commande
publique donc là vous avez un secteur
d'activité très important en France qui
vit essentiellement d'argent public
dans l'industrie c'est moins vrai mais
vous avez quand même dans la commande
publique la possibilité d'avoir des gros
marchés d'un coup qui sont des marchés
qui peuvent tirer l'innovation
donc parce que sur un gros marché vous
avez les moyens justement de financer la
montée en compétences ou la montée alors
je vais prendre un exemple c'est pas
très environnementalement friedlim est
quand même c'est l'armement dans
l'armement il y a je crois que ça
concerne la région donc il y a que de la
commande publique voilà et souvent les
hommes surtout plein de testostérone des
femmes beaucoup moins étant ce qu'ils
sont les innovations sont venues du
secteur militaire avant de s'étendre au
secteur civil c'est malheureux mais
c'est comme ça internet que vous
utilisez tous aujourd'hui c'est un
dérivé d'ARPANET qui était un programme
de recherche du département
des départements de la Défense
américaine qui voulait créer un réseau
résilient aux attaques nucléaires
donc le donc c'est comme ça voilà
l'histoire de l'histoire des
technologies c'est que on a quand même
fait beaucoup de choses d'abord pour se
taper dessus avant de savoir ce qu'on
pouvait en faire dans un autre contexte
ben là la commande publique est
absolument essentielle
donc vous avez il y a quand même un
certain nombre de domaines dans lesquels
la commande publique joue un rôle c'est
pas la seule alors pour que la commande
publique joue bien son rôle il faut que
les acheteurs soient formés
on peut pas qui sache quels sont les
bons critères qui sachent dans quelle
direction partir et là vous avez un truc
un point d'appui sur lequel on soulève
ou pas le monde pour reprendre le propos
d'Archimède qui est les normes et
méthodes qui sont utilisées dans les
cahiers des charges au moment des achats
alors là je vais prendre un exemple du
secteur automobile et pas un secteur de
la commande publique mais parce que j'en
ai entendu parler il y a pas longtemps
par quelqu'un qui bossait chez un
équipementier je sais plus si c'est je
crois que c'est BMW qui avait dit à ses
équipements entiers je vous achète que à
condition que vous ayez un plan pour
être neutre en carbone hachez plus trop
quel horizon de temps mais vous avez pas
le droit nucléaire
[Musique]
ah ouais non mais alors là le truc c'est
impossible l'équation est un petit peu
c'est un exemple pour montrer que à
partir du moment où on a un cahier des
charges qui est censé permettre
d'avancer dans la bonne direction en
fait tout va être dans le cahier des
charges d'accord et donc on peut pas
laisser les élus en l'air décidé de même
leur propre cahier des charges en plus
sinon si vous êtes un fournisseur
servant la commune de Cluses la commune
de Sallanches et la commune de La
Roche-sur-Foron et que les trois ont des
cahiers des charges différents bon
courage donc les uns voilà exactement
donc la commande publique en fait elle
doit se structurer l'appareil public
doit se doit ouvrir un chantier qui est
tout ce qui est énorme et label
il doit le faire de manière intelligente
et c'est compliqué pour une autre raison
que les gens dans cette salle savent
très bien c'est que la connaissance elle
est du côté des gens qui font et qui
innovent c'est à dire que l'acheteur
public au moment où il doit acquérir de
la connaissance manque de peau il
discute avec des gens qui sont jugés
partis c'est à dire ces futurs
fournisseurs qui manquent de peau sont
quand même ceux qui en savent le plus
long sur la question bon donc c'est très
très compliqué d'organiser ce dialogue
alors de temps en temps on peut trouver
des tiers genre des consultants des
machins etc moi c'est exactement ce que
j'ai fait au niveau du bilan carbone
j'étais ni le client ni fournisseur on
m'a foutu dans ma cave on va dire est un
an pour réfléchir
essaye de répondre à la question posée
notre personne ne l'est mais essaye de
répondre à la question posée qui est
comment est-ce qu'on mesure
intelligemment ou efficacement peu
importe
la dépendance aux émissions de gaz à
effet de serre d'accord comment est-ce
que on fait quelque chose qui a du sens
et qui va parler aux utilisateurs
on m'a pas demandé si ça allait
favoriser plutôt les assiéristes plutôt
le BTP plutôt les chimistes ou plutôt la
personne qui est ici en face de moi on
m'a pas posé la question on va juste
dire c'est quoi la bonne manière de
mesurer la dépense et donc le acheteur
public dans la collectivité locale il va
devoir se poser exactement la même
question c'est quoi la bonne manière
d'avoir quelque chose qui va dans la
bonne direction pour ce que je vais
acheter vis-à-vis de la contrainte
biodiversité climat ou ressources lui
n'a pas la réponse et les seuls qui ont
un peu réfléchi à la question parce que
c'est les seuls qui avaient intérêt à
mettre de l'argent dans la question
parce que c'est la contrainte qui va
leur tomber dessus c'est les gens qui
l'ont en face de lui
donc c'est donc voilà donc voilà voilà
un petit nogardien il y en a plein
d'autres voilà un petit nœud gordien
qu'il faut savoir détricoter
dans le sujet de la commande publique
mais oui la commande publique est quand
même sur le fond quelque chose qui est
un levier important d'accord mais avec
cette histoire de fait la poule entre
celui qui propose et celui dont qui a
besoin alors ce que je vous propose là
maintenant
tu ne bouges pas s'il te plaît tu te
relaxes tu bois un verre on va et sinon
on a quatre questions parce qu'on a
demandé aux personnes qui sont ici
d'envoyer les questions à l'avance comme
ça on pouvait bosser un peu et tout donc
pendant que vous discutez
on peut commencer par la quand même au
nord à ceux qui ont un peu bossé en
avance
Isabelle Escoffier d'inventis si vous
pensez que votre question n'a pas été où
êtes-vous elle est là si vous pensez que
votre question n'a pas été adressée
pendant la conférence
allez-y poser là c'est le moment alors
attention c'est une question pas une
déclaration il y a qu'une personne qui a
le droit de parler pour ne rien dire ici
c'est moi
de Noël n'a pas été posé
suite au réchauffement climatique en
fait tout le monde est focalisé sur la
transformation des énergies fossiles en
énergie verte
et j'avais envie de vous poser une
question est-ce que vous pensez que le
manque d'eau de plus en plus important
dans différents endroits du monde ne va
pas devenir le problème majeur à traiter
dans les décennies à venir puisqu'il
créera forcément des famines et des gros
problèmes d'insécurité du au mouvement
migratoire
alors je vais vous faire une réponse qui
est qui va pour partie vous paraître
cynique mais je vais quand même vous la
faire d'abord les deux sujets sont
interconnectés parce que avec de
l'énergie vous arrivez à avoir de l'eau
en particulier en dessalement l'eau de
mer aujourd'hui il y a des processus de
désalinisation de l'eau de mer avec des
on utilise du gaz pour avoir l'énergie
l'Espagne a déjà un certain nombre de
d'unités comme ça qui fonctionnent donc
c'est gênant pour les gens qui n'ont
accès qu'à l'eau pluviales et qui n'ont
pas les moyens économiques ni l'énergie
pour mettre en oeuvre des processus de
cette de cette nature
après vous avez également des endroits
où vous avez un manque d'eau en surface
mais vous avez des nappes d'eau fossiles
très importantes dans le sous-sol et
donc ça peut aussi pour un certain
nombre de décennies voire de siècles
permettent de faire la différence
les gens qui sont suffisamment mal en
point pour commencer à crever de faim
parce que ils ont pas assez d'eau en
général ils bougent pas beaucoup de là
où ils sont
quand vous regardez ce qui se passe en
Afrique par exemple en Afrique de l'Est
en particulier c'est pas de ces régions
là que viennent de l'essentiel des
migrants qu'on a en France
puisque ils sont tellement mal qui
bougent pas beaucoup donc le manque
d'eau il est il est quand il commence à
vous amener à un point tel que ça met en
danger la vie des gens
à ce moment-là en fait ça devient un
problème local c'est pas un problème à
large échelle on va dire le en France la
façon dont le manque d'eau va nous
impacter alors pardon au dernier point
c'est que le manque d'eau il est
évidemment très lié aussi au
réchauffement climatique
en fait le réchauffement climatique il
va avoir
macroscopiquement comme effet
d'augmenter l'évaporation parce qu'il
s'y fait plus chaud si l'air et plus
chaud il a une capacité d'emplaire en
vapeur d'eau qui est plus élevée par
ailleurs s'il fait plus chaud vous avez
plus d'évaporation et les deux tiers de
la surface planétaire c'est quand même
des océans donc vous avez plus
d'évaporation qui va avoir lieu et donc
globalement plus de précipitations
manque de chance l'essentiel du surplus
précipitation va avoir lieu sur les
océans eux-mêmes
sur les continents le pronostic c'est
que globalement les sols vont s'asser
alors vous avez quelques endroits qui
vont faire exception mais par exemple
tous les sols européens globalement vont
s'assécher à quelques exceptions près le
l'Amérique va globalement l'Amérique du
Nord et globalement ça sécher l'Amazonie
va s'assécher votre partie de la Chine
va s'asser etc donc globalement
ça ça va avoir comme conséquence de
baisser les rendements agricoles
de tuer une partie des écosystèmes donc
avec si vous avez un climat plus sec
vous pouvez avoir des chêne vert c'est
plus petit que les chaînes tout court
d'accord et puis le temps que les
chaînes tout court meurent et que vous
ayez les chênes verts à la place pendant
un moment vous avez pas grand chose
donc vous allez avoir ce genre de
problème ça va évidemment donc je le
disais tout à l'heure diminuer le
rendement des cultures et ça va
également diminuer le débit des fleuves
en particulier le débit des tirages et
ça c'est quelque chose qui peut gêner là
les écosystèmes aquatiques des fleuves
évidemment ça peut gêner le transport
fluvial vous avez eu l'exemple en
Allemagne
l'été dernier plus il y a trois étés en
2018 où le niveau du Rhin est tombé
tellement bas que il y avait un certain
nombre de barges qui pouvait plus passer
ça peut gêner les prélèvements d'eau des
industries et des centrales électriques
qui se trouvent en bord de fleuve toutes
les centrales thermiques ont besoin
d'eau pour se refroidir que ce soit du
clair à charbon à gaz alors en France on
est surtout concernés par le nucléaire
mais dans d'autres pays du monde par
exemple les centrales à charbon en bord
de rivière en Allemagne connaissent
exactement le même problème sur la
partie refroidissement je parle pas du
CO2 que les centrales nucléaires
françaises ça peut un peu diminuer la
production c'est pas un problème de
sûreté parce que on peut arrêter le
réacteur si vraiment il y a pas assez
d'eau pour refroidir en fonctionnement à
ce moment vous divisez la puissance par
1000 et donc là il reste toujours assez
d'eau pour leur fournir mais par contre
c'est un problème qui peut impacter le
niveau de production donc ça c'est clair
ça peut impacter la production des
barrages les barrages en France en 2022
ont significativement moins produit que
les années précédentes et l'énergie
renouvelable hydraulique en France à
l'avenir malheureusement il est peu
probable qu'elle augmente et plutôt
partie pour aller dans l'autre sens
donc vous allez voilà donc vous avez
tout un tas de tout un tas de défaits on
va dire du manque d'eau certains et si
vous voulez des chiffres en France
aujourd'hui on a 200 milliards de mètres
cubes d'eau qui tombe chaque année avec
la pluie
les prélèvements qu'on opère aujourd'hui
c'est à peu près 15 % de tout ça
si on devait perdre un quart de cette
eau vous voyez que macroscopiquement on
a encore de quoi assuré nos prélèvements
ce qui va souffrir c'est essentiellement
les écosystèmes qui ne sont pas irrigués
et les cultures qui ne sont pas
irriguées voilà c'est ça qui va souffrir
je sais pas si ça répond à votre
question
alors deuxième question
est-ce qu'on prend une question au
hasard parce que j'ai des questions
planifiées question de la salle
oui encore une question de femme avec
des amis
merci pour votre exposé globalement moi
ce que j'en ai compris c'est que j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a deux sujets il y
a le réchauffement climatique avec tout
ce que vous nous avez dresser très
factuel très chiffré très noir a priori
avec l'histoire du hammam et tout ça il
y a pas grand monde qui qui va s'en
sortir je ne vois pas quel avenir on a
dans le siècle qui vient il y a celui il
y a celui des ressources à la fin du
siècle qui vient comme moi vous serez
morte oui certes
mais les sons un peu les sons un peu
d'espoir à nos enfants il y a celui des
ressources
des ressources finies qui là où on voit
quand même un espoir parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a quand même une
grosse prise en compte avec
le tout ce qui est le recyclage le
l'économie circulaire etc donc il y a
probablement là des choses à faire mais
voilà sur le premier point qui est le
réchauffement climatique même si on
arrive à trouver des nouvelles
ressources en utilisant celle qui sont
actuellement là en faisant de nos
déchets des ressources et qu'on ne
puisse plus on ne puisse plus dans les
ressources actuelles quid du
réchauffement climatique est-ce que
finalement
l'augmentation des températures va finir
par nous avoir même si on ne puisse pas
dans la terre vous connaissez cette
maxime célèbre de Kens à long terme nous
sommes tous morts donc
alors le réchauffement climatique il va
d'une manière générale globalement avoir
des effets adverses
globalement il va pas y avoir grand
chose de bénéfique dans le réchauffement
climatique sauf les ventes de glace des
bistrotiers à court terme mais voilà
mais globalement c'est pas une bonne
affaire pour nous
aujourd'hui une partie de ce qui permet
de s'accommoder des premiers effets du
réchauffement climatique c'est
précisément l'abondance énergétique fait
trop chaud en climatisme
il y a pas assez d'eau dans les fleuves
on passe par camion
on a une inondation qui ravage tout on
amène les tractopelles c'est de
l'énergie le niveau de l'eau monte on
construit des digues vous voyez donc
tout ça c'est de l'énergie donc en fait
il faut bien voir que aujourd'hui ce qui
nous permet de bien de pas trop souffrir
on va dire des premières conséquences du
réchauffement climatique c'est
précisément l'abondance énergétique je
vais vous donner un exemple très
illustratif que moi j'aime bien enfin
les gens qui l'ont vécu n'aiment pas du
tout mais moi oui quand vous avez
l'ouragan Katrina qui intervient aux
États-Unis vous avez 1500 morts parce
que passer les morts immédiats de
l'ouragan ceux qui sont fait noyer
assommés par des trucs etc on a les
moyens grâce à l'abondance énergétique
des États-Unis d'amener la marée
chaussée pour empêcher et que ça
dégénère en pugilat de l'eau potable
d'évacuer les gens de leur amener à
bouffer etc vous prenez le même ouragan
au Bangladesh
ou en Birmanie je sais plus dans les
années 70 100000 morts c'est quoi la
différence entre les deux pas d'énergie
donc après l'ouragan il y a toujours
1000 personnes ou 1500 qui sont mortes
pendant l'ouragan les gens meurent tous
de maladies amenées par l'eau croupy
donc en gros ils doivent tous du choléra
parce que l'abondance énergétique n'est
pas là pour amener de l'eau saine et
pour amener des choses à manger voilà
c'est ça la différence donc ça c'est
très illustratif pour moi du fait que
l'abondance énergétique aujourd'hui
permet de répondre aux premières
manifestations du réchauffement
climatique malheureusement dans le
siècle qui vient on va avoir deux effets
qui vont se conjuguer pour nous
compliquer la vie les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique vont augmenter
avec une rémanence qui va être là même
alors même qu'on aura commencé à baisser
les émissions quand les effets vont
continuer à s'amplifier
et dans le même temps on va avoir une
moindre disponibilité des moyens de
faire face aux conséquences puisque
l'abondance énergétique va diminuer donc
on va avoir plus d'emmerdements à gérer
avec moins de moyens si je dis les
choses de manière un peu crue et c'est
l'effet ciseaux des deux qui est
susceptible de commencer à être assez
désagréable alors sur la question des
ressources ça dépend de ce qu'on fait
des ressources on parlait du titane tout
à l'heure est-ce que vous savez à quoi
sert l'essentiel du titane
pas du tout ça sert à faire les pigments
blancs dans les peintures
donc en fait 95% du titane est utilisé
dans des usages qu'on appelle dispersifs
et vous allez pas recycler le titane qui
est là je peux vous dire voilà il est
pas blanc enfin dans le studio là-bas
j'ai vu que c'était blanc donc vous avez
celui-là vous il est un recyclable
parce que la dépense énergétique qu'il
faudrait consentir pour aller récupérer
les quelques fractions de fourmille que
vous avez dans la peinture ou de pour
cent que vous avez dans la peinture que
vous avez soigneusement étalé au pinceau
en couche très fist en couche très mince
histoire de pas en consommer trop
partout sur les murs des bâtiments c'est
juste la dépense énergétique pour
récupérer tout ça elle est hors de
portée et en fait vous avez un tableau
que vous pouvez que vous pouvez
consulter dans dans des rapports sur la
question où vous avez le taux de
recyclage par élément du tableau de
modèle if et vous verrez que les
éléments qui se recyclent beaucoup vous
avez quelques métaux qui se recyclent
beaucoup et c'est à peu près tout
l'essentiel du reste ne pas je vais vous
prendre un autre exemple idiot l'hélium
une fois que vous avez utilisé l'hélium
il est parti dans l'atmosphère vous ne
recyclez pas l'hélium une fois qu'il est
dans l'atmosphère
c'est havable d'accord voilà donc on
recycle bien l'acier le cuivre
le plomb l'étain enfin voilà quelques
quelques grands et petits métaux
l'essentiel du reste et après en plus
vous avez des recyclages dans lesquels
vous gagnez de la ressource mais vous
gagnez pas d'énergie par exemple le
recyclage du papier ça c'est un truc que
peu de gens savent c'est pas moins
d'énergie que de faire du papier à
partir de bois
parce que le processus de désencrage du
papier déjà utilisé est un processus
très énergivore et ça je me rappelle
très bien au moment où j'avais travaillé
sur les premiers facteurs d'émission de
bilan carbone c'est un truc qui m'avait
beaucoup étonné donc le recyclage du
papier ça permet d'éviter de couper des
arbres donc ça c'est pas idiot mais par
contre ça ne permet pas d'éviter du CO2
mais il y a plein de ressources
aujourd'hui encore une fois qu'on est
pas capable de recycler de façon et puis
après vous avez de la substétuabilité
entre éléments qui n'est pas non plus
toujours possible
donc on va aussi avoir un sujet sur les
ressources
parce que comme je le disais tout à
l'heure extraire et recycler des
ressources c'est aussi de l'énergie donc
à partir du moment où vous avez pas
beaucoup d'énergie même certains
recyclages deviennent compliqués à faire
et est-ce que vous avez quand même
est-ce que vous avez quand même un
scénario un peu positif ou les scénarios
si le scénario pour avoir des petits
enfants qui pourront eux-mêmes avoir des
petits-enfants si le scénario un peu
positif c'est qu'on peut trouver des
choses à faire dans ce monde là la
réponse est oui si le scénario un peu
positif c'est que on va pouvoir
tranquillement se la couler douce comme
avant et bénéficier des mêmes choses au
même prix en même quantité la réponse
est non
c'est donc on va pas vivre
linéairement mieux que ou alors mieux
c'est différent un peu comme ce que
d'ici le mieux c'est différent quand
votre médecin vous dit que vous êtes
cassé vous êtes cassé la jambe je sais
pas s'il appelle ça un scénario possible
je sais pas si c'est un scénario positif
ou négatif mais c'est une information
dont vous êtes obligé de tenir compte
alors
on va devoir transpirer c'est évident
oui alors on a cassé l'ambiance bah
ouais
Damien Agez de décorer qu'est-ce que
votre question est vraiment différente
bah écoutez moi je pose la question par
rapport aux panneaux solaires
aujourd'hui notre électricité le
provient en France à 92% de l'un
nucléaire des énergies renouvelables
comme l'hydroélectricité est-ce que ça
fait sens du coup de mettre des panneaux
solaires comme on nous en fait la pub
sur nos toit d'usine ou sur les
ombrières pour protéger nos voitures du
soleil
le photovoltaïque en France il a
commencé à beaucoup se développer au
moment du Grenelle de l'environnement
le Grenelle de l'environnement est un
est une grande concertation dont vous
vous rappelez peut-être qu'il y avait
été organisé par Sarkozy après son
élection
et dans lequel Sarkozy avait dit on ne
parlera pas de nucléaire
les anti-nucléaires on dit a on parlera
pas de nucléaire très bien nous ne
parlerons pas de nucléaire on va juste
se contenter de faire la promotion des
énergies renouvelables électriques
[Musique]
voilà donc de cette époque là date le
fait que en France la politique sur les
énergies renouvelables a été
essentiellement sur des énergies
électriques pas du tout parce que
c'était pertinent pour le climat parce
que c'était vu par les anti-nucléaires
comme une manière de s'attaquer au
nucléaire et donc c'est pour ça que on a
fait un plan à l'allemande où là le
nucléaire était l'ennemi désigné
officiel
consistant à subventionner des éoliennes
et des panneaux solaires et à ce
moment-là l'argument mis en avant par
les gens qui soutenaient cette mesure
était effectivement de remplacer du
nucléaire alors sur le plan du CO2 on
gagne rien c'est très clair en fait on
perd même un peu parce que le soleil
exploitant une énergie diffuse parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de soleil sur terre
mais il y a beaucoup de surface sur
lequel tombent le soleil aussi donc par
mètre carré un pas tant que ça et bien
le fil rendement d'un panneau c'est 10
15%, c'est pas 100
plutôt 15 ça veut dire que le le solaire
il faut manipuler des quantités
significatives de matière pour faire le
collecteur qui va permettre de récupérer
l'énergie du soleil et à l'arrivée vous
avez à peu près 10 fois plus d'émissions
de CO2 par kilowattheure qu'avec du
nucléaire alors ça reste des petits
chiffres pour vous donner des ordres de
grandeur quand vous faites un
kilowatt-heure électrique avec du
charbon c'est 1 kg de CO2 par
kilowatt-heure électrique quand vous
faites avec du gaz c'est 400 g de CO2
par kilowatt-heure électrique avec du
nucléaire en France c'est 4 g par
kilowatt-heure électrique avec du
photovoltaïque on est plutôt à 40 vous
voyez ça reste faible par rapport au gaz
c'est 10 fois moins que le gaz donc
c'est vous pouvez mettre ça dans les
énergies back carbone mais c'est quand
même 10 fois plus que nucléaire d'accord
donc si vous remplacez du nucléaire par
du PV on n'a rien gagné même l'éolien
qui est à 10 g de CO2 par kWh vous
n'avez rien gagné non plus après il y a
un deuxième truc qu'il faut bien voir
c'est tant qu'on sait pas stocker
l'électricité à large échelle et avec
des moyens physiques accessibles vous ne
pouvez pas supprimer la centrale
nucléaire parce que vous mettez du
photovoltaïque vous pouvez juste pas
vous en servir quand il y a du soleil en
fait quand vous regardez ce qui s'est
passé en Allemagne
l'Allemagne alors je suis désolé j'ai
manipulé des chiffres encore mais vous
avez prévenu tout à l'heure je vous
ferai mal à la tête j'espère que vous
êtes venus avec du doliprane ou de
l'aspirine l'Allemagne avait 100 GW de
capacité électrique pilotable
c'est-à-dire celles qu'on peut augmenter
et baisser à la demande indépendamment
du vent et du soleil en 2002 là dedans
vous aviez du charbon du gaz du
nucléaire de l'hydroélectricité
en 2022 l'Allemagne a toujours 100
gigawatts de capacité pilotable moins de
nucléaires plus de gaz
à ça elle a rajouté 120 gigawatts à date
on doit même être à 130 d'éolien et de
solaire donc l'éolien et le solaire
n'ont pas permis de faire baisser la
capacité pilotable installée simplement
le facteur de charge de cette capacité
pilotable lui il a perdu 15%. c'est à
dire au lieu de s'en servir la moitié de
l'année on s'en sert à 35 % du temps
mais on est obligé de les garder parce
que sinon les industriels allemands
n'ont pas d'électricité quand il y a pas
de vent et pas de soleil
et comme les industriels allemands vos
compétiteurs sont pas du tout des gens
qui ont envie de se passer de produire
quand il y a pas de vent et pas de
soleil enfin en tout cas c'est pas comme
ça que vous les connaissez je pense et
bien l'Allemagne a donc dupliqué les
capacités installées des capacités
renouvelables plus des capacités
pilotables enfin des capacités
renouvelables intermittentes éolien
solaire plus des capacités pilotes du
coup à l'arrivée c'est normal que le
système veille plus cher puisque on a
doublé les capacités donc c'est normal
que le prix de l'électricité est
fortement augmenté dans tous les pays
européens qui ont déployé de l'éolien et
du solaire c'est on peut on peut le
faire pour de bonnes raisons c'est pas
le sujet mais le sujet c'est que c'est
fatalement ça fait augmenter le prix
global
alors installer de l'éolien du soleil
dans des pays qui ont des centrales à
charbon il y a gaz pour éviter
d'utiliser du charbon et du gaz quand il
y a du vent et du soleil c'est pas idiot
c'est même un truc à faire donc que la
Pologne et l'Allemagne installe des
éoliennes et des panneaux solaires pour
remplacer une partie du charbon qu'ils
utilisent ça c'est intelligent par
contre ça ne permettra pas d'aller
jusqu'au bout du chemin
puisque tant qu'on a pas réglé le
problème de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement quand il y a pas de
vent et pas de soleil
vous ne pouvez pas supprimer les
capacités fossiles qui sont là en backup
donc si on veut être net 0 il manque un
maillon dans l'histoire qui est la
capacité de stocker à très large échelle
sur plusieurs mois parce que le problème
il se pose pas à l'échelle de la journée
à l'échelle de la journée les batteries
des voitures électriques vont faire le
job mais par contre à l'échelle de
plusieurs mois c'est inenvisageable
tout le lithium des réserves prouvés
aujourd'hui dans le monde alors
évidemment il y aura d'autres réserves
peu importe permettrait de stocker trois
jours de production électrique dans le
monde
sur batterie donc vous voyez on va
jamais faire des batteries à large
échelle pour stocker ce réseau c'est
même enfin les opérateurs de réseau vous
leur posez la question et oui j'avais de
la vie ça n'arrivera jamais
sur réseau pour stocker à large échelle
il faut faire du gaz en fait il faut
hydroliser il faut
électrolisé pardon de l'eau faire de
l'hydrogène faire du gaz de synthèse
vous pouvez éventuellement aussi
imaginer avoir du biogaz mais quand vous
regardez les quantités qu'il faut il en
faut quand même beaucoup beaucoup
pour contrebalancer l'intermittence des
énergies renouvelables et à partir du
moment où vous faites ça avec de
l'hydrogène j'ai généré par électrolyse
le rendement de chaîne électricité
vergaz et gaz vers électricité à
l'arrivée c'est 25%. donc vous devez
multiplier par 4 la production
électrique que vous allez devoir stocker
sur des mois
donc c'est enfin voilà donc c'est c'est
ça le No gordien du système faire une
éolienne c'est très simple faire un
système complet basé sur des éoliennes
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que de
faire un système complet basé sur des
votes pilotable
en bas carbone vous avez
l'hydroélectricité nucléaire en haut
carbone vous rajoutez le charbon et le
gaz en gros
voilà donc en France avoir voulu
remplacer du nucléaire par des panneaux
solaires et des éoliennes étaient
personnellement quelque chose auquel je
me suis opposé que le succès de concept
puisque c'est ça qu'on a fait quand même
parce que je considère que c'était une
perte de temps et d'argent pour toutes
les raisons que je viens de vous évoquer
et que c'était même pas ça qui allait
nous permettre de nous débarrasser des
centrales nucléaires quand bien même on
aurait pensé que c'était très dangereux
puisqu'il fallait qu'on les garde en
capacité de pilotable de backup d'accord
donc voilà aujourd'hui quand on quand on
déploie donc ce genre de en fait les
gens à qui on rend service il y a nos
voisins donc ce qui se passe c'est que
on décarbonne surtout l'électricité des
voisins avec les éoliennes et les
panneaux solaires qu'on installe chez
nous mais là il y a un tout petit sujet
économique je vois pas pourquoi c'est
les Français qui payeraient de quoi
décarboner l'électricité allemande
surtout que les Allemands ont plus de
pognon que nous on va vraiment pas et
quand les Allemands se sont battus à
l'Europe pour avoir les interconnexions
en fait c'est ça qui réclame il réclame
la possibilité de pouvoir décarboner
leur électricité consommer chez eux
notamment avec les investissements faits
par les voisins
donc tout ça peut éventuellement flotter
avec des contreparties avec un truc bien
pensé avec etc mais en fait aujourd'hui
il y a quand même quelques trucs qui
n'ont pas été bien pensé dans le système
et notamment le fait encore une fois que
substituer des énergies des carbonées
entre elles c'était probablement pas
urgence
voilà alors en et si vous avez le temps
je vous invite alors c'est beaucoup plus
long que moi ce soir si vous dire si
c'est long comme disait l'autre
je vous invite à regarder toutes les
auditions filmées publiques d'une
commission d'enquête qui a eu lieu à la
fin qui est en ce moment en train de
travailler à l'Assemblée nationale alors
bon il y a eu des manov politiciennes à
mon avis derrière la création des cette
commission d'enquête parce que c'est sa
républicain qu'il a préside bon bref peu
importe donc cette commission d'enquête
elle s'appelle la commission d'enquête
sur la perte d'indépendance et de
souveraineté énergétique de la France
oubliez le titre on s'en fout il y a 50
auditions qui durent entre deux et trois
heures chacune donc je vous assure que
vous avez le temps d'éplucher les
patates en les moi j'ai épluché beaucoup
de patates on les fait cuire beaucoup de
pâtes en écoutant les auditions
et là dedans tout y passe les anciens
présidents DDF et l'actuel les anciens
industriels de l'énergie nucléaire les
industriels actuels et passer du pétrole
donc vous avez le flop Prigent qui est
passé vous avez de Marjorie qui est
passé vous avez engie donc McGregor qui
est passé vous n'avez pas trop de
Framatome qui est passé enfin voilà
c'est écoutez c'est super instructif
vous pensez ce que vous voulez du
nucléaire de l'éol on s'en fout c'est
extrêmement intéressant de voir comment
est-ce que les gens déroulent leur
vision de la situation et pour une fois
je tire mon chapeau à du travail de
parlementaire moi qui est facilement la
denture avec les politiques parce que
vraiment ils ont bossé vous voyez que
les questions qui posent sont pas des
questions à côté de la plaque c'est
enfin voilà ils ont ils ont creusé le
sujet les débats sont calmes c'est pas
la foire d'empoigne les tons est posé
enfin vraiment c'est c'est très
intéressant donc allez écouter et vous
aurez une histoire de la politique
énergétique de la France sur les 20
dernières années
vous aurez un décryptage vraiment
intéressant de de ce qui s'est passé et
je vous conseille de démarrer par le
début on pourrait zapper mon
intervention qui au début parce que ça
vous allez rien apprendre mais parce que
vous avez déjà eu tout ce soir mais mais
commencez par le début parce que c'est
au début qu'ils ont fait venir des gens
qui ont une vision un peu large sur le
système énergétique et des voilà et qui
sont pas directement des industriels du
secteur
puis après vous allez voir c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment intéressant et
bon sentiment c'est qu'on est
malheureusement un peu parti dans le
décor à cette époque là c'est à dire au
lieu de s'occuper de faire de la
sobriété et de la défaussiliation on
s'est occupé de la guerre entre les pros
les Antilles nucléaires voilà je pense
qu'on a perdu du temps en tout cas ça me
rappelle que j'ai complètement oublié
quand j'étais présenté là tu es en train
de dire que tu fréquentes des politiques
et des hauts fonctionnaires et que tu es
au conseil pour le climat donc donc
voilà tu as toute cette autre vision de
l'intérieur très peu de politique au
conseil pour le climat ils viennent pas
en fait ils s'en foutent on leur demande
pas de venir
ce que vous ce que vous produisez à mon
grand arbre du reste parce que moi il y
a un des trucs que j'aimerais bien faire
c'est qu'on les convoque en audition
public filmer filmer non mais filmer
quand on voit les pour revenir à cette
commission d'enquête
une des vidéos les plus vues de ma pomme
sur Internet maintenant c'est l'audition
à cette commission d'enquête le un
ancien au commissaire à l'énergie
atomique je sais même pas s'il y a des
gens dans la salle qui savent ce que
c'est que cette fonction SI quand même
Yves Rocher il a fait entre 100 et
150000 vues sur sa vidéo donc c'est un
exercice de transparence de la vie
démocratique qui remarquable
vraiment voilà
donc la confrontation aux politiques on
n'a pas au conseil pour le climat on est
entre nous et on pond des documents on
leur envoie
on n'en sait rien voilà normalement ma
fréquentation du politique elle est liée
au fait que ça fait maintenant une
vingtaine d'années que temps à autre je
vais très déléguêtres dans un ministère
où elle Élysée pour voir déconseiller le
plus souvent des ministres de temps en
temps des hauts fonctionnaires de temps
en temps donc elle est là ma
fréquentation et des élus locaux ça
m'arrive aussi de temps en temps c'est
moins fréquent parce que je fréquente
plus la classe politique on va dire
nationale député sénateur etc les élus
locaux ça m'arrive de temps en temps
typiquement à l'occasion ce genre
d'exercice c'est à dire quand je sors de
pas quand j'accepte de sortir de Paris
donc quand je sors de Paris donc quand
je peux le faire c'est toujours avec
plaisir
il m'arrive de faire des interventions
dans des endroits où les élus locaux
sont là et à ce moment j'ai toujours
taper la discute avec eux parce que
c'est intéressant maintenant puis on t'a
pas encore cloné donc il y a qu'un
Jean-Marc Jancovici donc faut bien que
tu ailles là-haut c'est
alors est-ce qu'on a encore le temps
pour des questions oui non
je sais pas
est-ce que la raclette c'est totalement
transformée serait totalement
transformée en huile sur la question
c'est totalement transformé en huile il
est temps d'arrêter
alors petite question d'abord un bonjour
de Bernard coyet qui j'étais ce matin
voilà qui lui aussi vous pouvez le voir
à une Angie qui traite sur du nucléaire
effectivement le monde sans fin de
remettre tranquille jusqu'à 2100 moi je
conseille à tout le monde y compris les
auditions notamment pour Lio le
haut-commissaire Jean-Claude etc moi ma
question c'est de savoir si réellement
il y a aucune possibilité puisque dans
le monde sans fin vous vous concluez
finalement qu'on va vers un monde de les
croissances est-ce que c'est inéluctable
est-ce qu'il y a un chemin
qui nous permettrait quand même de je
dirais conserver un tout petit peu de
croissance parce que sinon si on va vers
un monde de décroissance comment
pourrait-on empêcher que des Chinois les
Indiens qui voudraient avoir la vie
qu'on a aujourd'hui en France
finalement nos snap pas dessus on ne
viennent pas nous taper dessus et qu'on
éclaire un petit peu une guerre mondiale
qui est ce qui permet à l'humain souvent
de un peu tout casser pour rebondir
alors malheureusement le gros mot est
arrivé
malheureusement nous n'échapperons pas
plus à la décroissance des flux que vous
et moi des chapeaux vieillissement voilà
donc il faut faire avec
ce pas très drôle le vieillir toujours
pour tout mais il faut faire avec parce
que sinon de toute façon on peut pas
faire sens c'est un truc physique
[Musique]
j'ai dit tout à l'heure sur toutes les
ressources non renouvelables
c'est mathématiquement démontrable que
on passe par un maximum de la
consommation et que ça décroît derrière
comme ça donc la décroissance des flux
physique elle arrivera de toute façon et
en fait en Europe elle a déjà commencé
quand vous regardez je vais vous donner
deux flux physiques en Europe les tonnes
chargés dans les camions
et la quantité de mètres carrés qu'on
construit par an
et bien pour ces deux indicateurs là et
c'est de nouveau pas un hasard avec 2008
et le pic de production du pétrole le
maximum c'était 2007
le maximum de mètres carrés construit
dans l'année en Europe ça a été de 2007
depuis et ceux d'entre vous dans la
salle qui servent l'industrie de la
construction savent peut-être que en
tendance depuis cette année-là on
construit de moins en moins et c'est
parti pour enfin voilà
les taux de chargés dans les camions
c'est pareil on est passé par un maximum
en 2007 tout simplement parce que avec
moins d'énergie parce que
l'approvisionnement énergétique de
l'Europe est passé par un maximum et
donc avec moins d'énergie on transforme
brin si on transforme moins on fait
moins de produits en tonnage et donc on
en charge moins dans les camions voilà
donc et ça ça va continuer alors est-ce
que ça va nécessairement nous rendre
malheureux ça dépend où on se situe
si nous considérons qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes un peu des obèses énergétiques
est-ce que ça va nous faire du mal de
diminuer notre consommation d'énergie
pas nécessairement
après si je continue ce parallèle il y a
un seuil en dessous duquel ça commence
vraiment à vous faire mal même si vous
mangez trop le fait de diminuer diminuer
diminuer à un moment il vaut mieux
s'arrêter de diminuer et en fait c'est
ce moment-là qui va commencer à être
vraiment difficile alors on n'est pas du
tout aujourd'hui moi je pense qu'on est
très au dessus du seuil c'est à dire que
il y a une bonne partie de la
décroissance qui peut se faire sans
grande douleur la décroissance physique
si on diminue significativement le
kilométrage en avion des Français dans
l'année alors c'est emmerdant parce
qu'il faut reconvertir Airbus sur
d'autres bonheur à doux bon à part qu'on
n'aura pas le snobisme de dire un dîner
en ville qu'on est allé aux Seychelles
on s'en fout un peu quoi quelque part il
y a de très beaux paysages en France et
les moments les plus heureux de notre
vie sont pas nécessairement ceux qu'on
est allés plus loin donc bon
et puis on fera comme font comme comme
peuvent on a encore un peu de marge
avant que on ne puisse plus du tout
faire ce que font une partie des jeunes
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire il se prennent
une année sabbatique et il court le
monde sans avion en vélo en train je
sais pas quoi ils découvrent le vaste et
en fait ils vont beaucoup plus voir le
monde que quelqu'un qui aurait fait 15
vols en avion pour aller au Club Med à
chaque fois
non
donc donc on a de la marge pour avoir
pour faire des choses qui restent
intéressantes
dans un monde dans lequel on a moins
d'énergie et puis c'est pareil si au
lieu de se déplacer dans une bagnole
d'une tonne et demi on se déplace dans
une bagnole de 500 kg ou à vélo
électrique je suis pas sûr que ça va
nous rendre fondamentalement
au bout de notre vie quoi comme dirait
certain voilà donc je pense qu'on a par
contre c'est une affaire alors cette
affaire là est une affaire
d'organisation c'est une affaire de
désir collectif c'est une affaire
d'équité parce que plein de gens vont se
dire il y a pas de raison que je roule
dans une bagnole à 500 kg pendant que
monsieur Bernard Arnault continue à
voler dans son jet privé donc il y a
donc les défis sont plus là pour moi ils
sont dans le récit qu'on est capable de
se raconter ils sont dans les objectifs
qu'on décape dans les valeurs qu'on est
capable de partager dans la façon dont
on se représente l'équité etc c'est
beaucoup plus là le le défi que
véritablement dans l'enjeu de diminuer
la consommation matière parce que je
pense qu'on a quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de gras
c'est quand on sera à l'os que ça sera
vraiment dur mais pour le moment on y
est pas donc
je pense que pour répondre à la question
sur les Indiens si vous fumez 20
cigarettes par jour qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez raconter à quelqu'un qui en fume
trois sur le fait que c'est pas bien de
fumer rien donc tant qu'on n'a pas fait
chez nous de toute façon une partie du
boulot c'est même pas la peine de se
poser la question de savoir ce qu'on va
raconter aux Indiens alors les Chinois
on a rien à la raconter non plus parce
que le milliard et quelques de chinois
aujourd'hui c'est 400 millions
d'Américains et 800 millions d'Indiens
c'est ça la Chine aujourd'hui vous avez
400 millions d'habitants sur les côtes
qui vivent comme vous et moi peu de
choses près et vous avez 800 millions de
gens ailleurs que dans les dans les
villes et sur la côte qui vivent eux
plutôt comme des Indiens c'est un peu
caricatural mais c'est pour les 400
millions qui vivent et qui sont aux
commandes par ailleurs
vous leur racontez rien non plus toute
façon ils vivent déjà comme vous
donc je ne crois pas que on est grand
chose à leur dire tant que nous on n'est
pas capable de s'organiser alors on me
posait la question tout à l'heure est-ce
que j'ai quand même un message d'espoir
oui j'en ai un on est les champions du
monde du système D
je vais vous le dire autrement on est
les champions du monde de l'optimisation
sous contrainte
on fait il faut accepter de se le dire
parmi les meilleurs ingénieurs au monde
parce que il y a une culture en France
et c'est ça qui fait qu'on est bon aux
deux extrémités du spectre on est bon
dans la démerde individuelle donc on
fait des bons architectes des bons
couturiers des bons pâtissiers des bons
etc et on est bon dans l'organisation
des grands systèmes complexes quand on
n'essaye pas d'imiter l'économie
libérale des autres qui n'aiment pas ça
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a fait avant de
commencer à mettre des trucs qui
marchaient pas dedans parce qu'on a
voulu imiter chez pas qui on a fait un
système électrique remarquable on a fait
un système ferroviaire remarquable on a
fait un système hospitalier remarquable
donc on est très très bon dans
l'organisation il y a que les français
pour s'en prendre de tout ça on est très
très bon dans l'organisation des grands
systèmes complexes or le problème que
j'ai évoqué ce soir il va demander de
l'ingéniosité de la créativité de
l'optimisation sous contrainte et de la
gestion des grands systèmes complexes
donc j'ai envie de dire c'est pour nous
faut qu'on fonce c'est pour nous par
contre il faut qu'on le fasse
intelligemment et donc il faut pas qu'on
le fasse en essayant de courir 50
lièvres à la fois et il faut pas non
plus qu'on le fasse en se trompant de
cahier des charges ce qu'on a fait le
coup PV versus nucléaire ça c'est une
erreur de cahier des charges a perdu
notre temps on a perdu nos cervelles on
aurait mieux fait de leur faire faire
autre chose mais si on est
fonceur j'ai envie de dire dans cette
direction là moi je pense qu'on a un
avenir à ce titre je pense qu'on a un
avenir mais c'est une faire conclusion
parce que déjà on avait besoin d'un
petit peu d'optimisme
pas vrai
mais il faut faire chez soi d'abord vous
êtes tous bien placés pour savoir car
l'international ça se conquiert pas tant
qu'on est pas bon sur son marché
domestique donc il faut qu'on fasse chez
nous d'abord
je trouve que c'est canon je voudrais
vous remercier pour votre attention
parce que normalement c'est 18 minutes
maximum la tension là ça doit faire 3h30
qu'on est ensemble on s'adore toujours
il y a un truc entre nous je trouve donc
on va
clore sauf si tu as
une dernière chose
moi je trouve que le moi je trouve que
c'était positif et ouais on peut
[Applaudissements]
alors
j'ai un petit truc à dire
je crois que Jean-Marc meurt de soif
parce que il y a voilà et donc oui mais
j'essaye de j'essaye de t'aider là
donc ce qui serait bien c'est que la
foule s'écarte pour laisser passer
Jean-Marc parce que sinon tout le monde
va lui sauter dessus en décembre j'ai
déjà vu comme ça alors en parlant par
contre par contre il y a de quoi manger
oui alors là de temps en temps je
j'interromprais peut-être mes réponses
15 secondes le temps de mâcher une
bouchée parce que sinon effectivement je
ne mange pas donc je pense que
il y a un petit message personnel c'est
une autre référence à une chanson de
Françoise Hardy
je crois que tu as pas super envie de
signer des trucs parce que sinon tu
pourras ni boire ni manger donc
mais si on je suis désolé j'ai un
traitement égalitaire pour les dédicaces
il y a un certain qui sont venus avec
des bouquins parce que en général quand
il y en a un qui sort un bouquin et je
dis oui il y en a 50 autres qui
apparaissent et comme j'ai horreur de
faire des dédicaces à la chaîne que
j'aime bien savoir à qui je dédicace et
pourquoi ça me prend deux minutes par
dédicace donc tous ceux dans la salle
qui peut faire une règle de trois 50
fois deux j'y passe 100 minutes donc
voilà je ne fais que ça voilà bonsoir
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]